good
morning today is a solemn occasion as
this committee begins official
impeachment proceedings in the matter of
Department of Homeland Security
secretary Alejandra mayaras and his
handling of America's borders since
taking office in February
20121 I wish we weren't sitting here
today I wish these proceedings were not
necessary I wish our Southwest border
was
Secure I wish that our government was
enforcing the laws pass by the Congress
and doing its job to keep the American
people safe unfortunately secretary
Marcus has done none of these things for
almost a year the house committee on
homeland security has conducted a
comprehensive investigation into the
causes costs and consequences of the
unprecedented crisis at our Southwest
border our evidence makes it clear
secretary mayorcas is the architect of
the devastation that we have witnessed
for nearly 3 years the findings of of
our investigation available to the
public at homeland.
house.gov coupled with the secretary's
refusal to change course on The Reckless
decisions facilitating this crisis have
left us with no reasonable alternative
than to pursue the possibility of
impeachment the secretary's actions have
brought us here today not
ours since early 2021 we've watched in
disbelief as historic numbers of
inadmissible aliens have poured across
our our borders both at official ports
of entry and illegally crossing the
thousands of miles of our borders on
secretary Marcus's watch Customs and
Border Protection has recorded more than
8.1 million encounters at America's
borders including more than 6.7 million
at our Southwest border alone for
comparison CBP recorded just over 3
million encounters Nationwide from
fiscal year 2017 to 2020
Jay Johnson President Obama's former DHS
secretary previously said that a
thousand encounters A Day quote
overwhelms the system end quote on
secretary Marcus's watch encounters have
never averaged less than 3,000 per day
even going as high as 10 to 12,000 per
day just a few days ago internal CBP
numbers leaked to the media showed
another
302,000 encoun at the Southwest border
alone in December by far an alltime
record that's nearly enough people to
fill the Rose Bowl three times in just
one month in addition to these
catastrophic numbers of the record 1.8
million known Goda ways who've entered
the country on secretary amicus's watch
individuals that border patrol agents
know slip across our border but are not
apprehended in large part because the
cartels overwhelm the agents with large
groups of coyote paid and escorted
migrants the agents see them and they
count them but they cannot apprehend
them but the numbers are most certainly
far worse as agents are moved to
Crossing sites to process migrants and
the border is completely unmanned there
are no agents present to count the known
Goda ways the number of unknown Goda
ways is no doubt
enormous thousands of Agents have been
pulled off the front lines to process
and release into our country record
numbers of illegal aliens who know they
will be released into the country and
given a free bus or plane ticket to the
city of their choice I ask you to watch
this
video a border shutdown in elb Paso
Texas as hundreds forced their way onto
the B de Norte international bridge
title 42 has officially expired Homeland
Security officials say illegal border
crossings topped 10,000 per day this
week the highest levels ever thousands
of migrants in central Mexico continue
to travel on freight trains and travel
all the way to the southern border
arriving here in Eagle Pass outnumbered
and out resourced border patrol agents
say they are struggling to keep up with
this massive influx of migrants
descending on our Southern border border
patrol clearly does not have the
manpower to process the thousands of
migrants here so the situation is pretty
dire hundreds upon hundreds of adult men
who have crossed illegally waiting here
in the Arizona Sun for border patrol to
apprehend them and uh they hope be
released into the United States
somewhere sources telling news nation
that agents have been pulled from nearby
checkpoints to assistant processing that
thousands of migrants Crossing into
Eagle Pass every day and this is all by
Design the Smugglers realize that this
particular area is
vulnerable what Americans must
understand to today is that these
historic numbers the chaos you just saw
on the screen are the result of a much
deeper problem and that problem is not
instability in other countries it's not
poverty it's not climate change it's not
supposedly broken immigration system all
of these excuses have long predated
secretary Marcus's tenure and yet we've
never experienced a crisis like this as
even the New York Times admits and I
quote push factors don't explain the
entire Surge and maybe not even most of
it there have been no recent Wars in
Latin America and the Region's poverty
rate has been flat in quote the New York
Times I'll also note that uh two of the
16 cities in the world with the highest
murder rates are right here in the
United States now this crisis has been
intentional secretary me orcus was made
aware of testimony given by President
Biden's attorney general Merrick Garland
where the AG admitted the current
policies are being exploited by the
cartels
yet secretary mayus turns around and
implements additional policies to expand
the Catch and Release measures
empowering the cartels and killing
Americans after nearly three years of
watching this unfold what other
conclusion is there but this is an
intentional crisis secretary May Arcus
has brazenly refused to enforce the laws
passed by Congress has and enacted
policies that knowingly make our country
less safe what we're seeing here is a
willful violation of his oath of office
taken by secretary marus let me repeat
that a willful
violation secretary Marcus has used Mass
to Rel release more than 1.5 million
inadmissible aliens into the country
despite the immigration and nationality
act stating that parole is to be used
only as an I quote Case by casee end
quote and quote temporary basis for a
quote significant benefit or urgent
humanitarian reason end quote the chief
Patrol agent of the border patrols Laro
sector told us last June that
historically parole and I quote was used
only in extreme humanitarian instances
if a child was sick had to go to the
hospital we'd parole the parent in a
some in or something like that but that
was very rare it wasn't an everyday
thing end quote this Porter Chief is
right the scale of secretary marcus'
Mass use and abuse of parole is
unprecedented and has been declared
inconsistent with the laws passed by
Congress by multiple federal
judges but remains a central component
of secretary's agenda the immigration
and nationality act also requires that
illegal aliens apprehended crossing the
boorder be detained pending their
removal proceedings secretary me Arcus
has ignored this law in fiscal year 2013
according to dhs's own numbers the Obama
Administration detained 82% of illegal
aliens from the moment they were
encountered until their case was decided
and another 9% were held for at least
some time some portion of time after
that that's a pretty good track record
and under a Democrat
Administration in Secretary Marcus's
first year on the job that 82% number
dropped to just 10% illegal aliens not
detained at all jumped from 9% to 64% in
fy21 in a court opinion earlier this
year federal judge Kent
weel wrote and I quote the evidence
establishes that in late January or
early February of 2021 DHS made a
discret change in detention policy from
release only if there is a compelling
reason to to release unless there is a
compelling reason not to end quote the
deputy chief of the boorder of patrols
Yuma sector told our committee in
September quote the belief that they are
going to be released with no
consequences is certainly something
something that many migrants tell our
agents end quote on secretary Marcus's
watch that's a pretty good bet and under
his leadership individuals guilty of
violent crimes and even some of the on
the terrorist watch list have been
released into this country just Monday
multiple sources confirmed secretary
meus admitted that released rates of
illegal aliens are currently around
85% all told DHS numbers indicate that
well over 3 million inadmissible alens
ions have been released into our country
on secretary Marcus's watch factor in
the 1.8 million known goway the UN
qualifiable unknown Goda ways that's
roughly the population of the state of
South Carolina not only has secretary
meus refuse to detain these individuals
in accordance with the law but he has
also made it nearly impossible for
immigrations and Customs Enforcement to
remove them his policies have largely
restricted the ability of ice to detain
and remove the popul ation of illegal
aliens ice removes ice removals dropped
from more than
267,000 in
fy19 to less than 60,000 in fy21 and
70,000 in 22 the FY 23 numbers were
better but were still more than 40,000
fewer than the lowest year of the last
Administration which largely occurred in
the midst of Co the covid pandemic
criminals as a percentage of all ice
arrests went from around 90% in fy2 2020
to just 43% in FY 23 the secretary is
not even living up to his own flawed
standards that supposedly prioritize
threats to Public Safety the former
sector Chief in San Diego told us in May
of 2023 that he didn't think the
consequences of being removed from the
country was being utilized enough to
deter illegal immigration even Texas
Democrat Mr quar has said and I quote if
you don't detain people if you don't
send people back then the Border becomes
a speed bump end quote on top of all
this upon entering office secretary
marus immediately began dismantling
effective policies that had secured the
Southwest border despite being warned by
experienced border security Personnel
the consequences that would result that
coupled with his consistent decision to
double down on his own unlawful policies
indicates an intentionality to this
crisis and I must note with great
emphasis these are not simple policy
differences this is a yearslong pattern
of refusing to enforce the laws passed
by Congress our investigation also
uncovered the fact that secretary meus
has VI violated the authority of his
office secretary meus has directed a
department to create numerous new
unlawful Mass parole programs that have
allowed an unprecedented number of
individuals to enter our country who
otherwise would have no lawful basis to
be here and to incentivize migrants to
make the dangerous in some sometimes
deadly travel to our Southern border he
has also effectively told ice officers
not to do their job in enforcing
America's immigration laws according to
his own guidance to ice and I quote the
fact an individual is removable should
not alone be the basis of an enforcement
action against them end quote end quote
our Personnel should not rely on the
fact of conviction end quote for a
flatly deportable crime but must
consider quote mitigating factors that
mitigate mate in favor of declining
enforcement action end quote he has even
overseen The Reckless and irresponsible
use of federal law enforcement Personnel
to sweep under the rug the mess he's
made at the Southwest border border
patrol Agents from the northern border
have been deployed to the Southwest
border to assist in processing and
releasing illegal aliens into the
interior hundreds of law enforcement
professionals from Homeland security
investigations have been pulled from
serious investigations like sex crimes
child exploitation and other atrocities
to perform administrative functions at
the border one whistleblower claimed
that his team was told to shut down its
investigations and were then sent to the
border to make sandwiches the secretary
has abused his authority and put
Americans at risk secretary morcus has
repeatedly lied to the American people
and to the United States Congress our
investigation Undercover more than 100
instances where secretary morcus misled
the public notably he claimed in April
2022 hearing to have operational control
of the Southwest border as defined by
federal statute this was false he then
told another U Lie by claiming in
subsequent hearings that he does not use
the statutory definition of operational
control despite doing so in that 2022
hearing watch for
yourself will you testify under oath
right now do we have operational control
yes or no yes we do and we have
operational control of the borders yes
we do and Congressman we are working to
list what operational control defined in
this section the term operational
control means the prevention of all
unlawful entries into the United States
including entries by terrorists other
unlawful aliens instruments of terrorism
narcotics and other Contraband do you
stand by on your testimony that we have
operational control in light of this
definition you and Congressman I think
the Secretary of Homeland Security would
have said the same thing in 2020
and in 2019 that's the definition of
oper definition you have sir up there no
we don't have operational control no sir
with respect to the definition of
operational control I do not use the
definition that appears in the secure
fence act do you admit that your
policies have led the country farther
away from operational control of the
Border as defined by the
Congress Congressman no I do not if you
will recall when you testified here in
front of me when I asked that question
when you very clearly stated we do have
operational control when presented with
the actual definition of operational
control you didn't hesitate you said I
do and you in fact then referred back
and said I believe that my predecessors
would have said the same thing you look
straight at the American people straight
at me straight at every every person on
this committee and said we have
operational
control why Congress
two points one you did not let me
complete my answer two hold on it's give
your second Point go ahead thank you two
two the secure fence act defines
operational control as not a single
individual crosses the bo I'm aware I
read it and I read it to you and you
read it and in fact you said I do you
didn't hesitate you didn't say I do I
need I need to explain what I mean by I
do you said I do over and over
again secretary Americus told this very
Committee in September 2021 and I quote
the border is no less secure than it was
previously end quote CBP recorded more
than 192,000 encounters at our border
that month alone compared to around
58,000 the prior September it was clear
the Border was not secure so why did he
mislead
Congress another video please
is the Border more secure under your
leadership than when you started uh
Congressman the border is secure we're
executing our plan and I've been very
clear and unequivocal in that regard M
Mr secretary the question is is the
Border more secure now under your
leadership Congressman it is no less
secure than it was previously we have
have a record number of retirements
historic level of Narcotics that have
come across the border and you still
stand by your statement yes or no that
the border is
secure
yes he even stood at the White House
podium in September 21 and falsely
accused mounting border patrol a mounted
border patrol agents in the Del Rio
sector of whipping illegal aliens
crossing the border earlier that same
day DHS emails showed that his staff had
informed him that an eyewitness said no
whipping occurred yet he Advanced The
Narrative at the highest levels anyway
one sector Chief told us and I quote we
never whipped anybody it was never
really cleared up and that takes a toll
on our agents end quote please play the
video we are very troubled by what we
have seen uh one cannot weaponize a
horse uh to aggressively attack a child
we know that those images painfully
conjured up the worst elements of our
nation's ongoing battle against systemic
racism uh first of all uh the images as
I expressed uh earlier uh the images
horrified Us in terms of what they
suggest and what they conjure up in
terms of not only our nation's history
but unfortunately the fact that that
page of History has not been turned
entirely and that means that there is
much work to do and we are very focused
on doing it an email obtained through a
records request reveals that DHS
secretary Alejandra Boris was privately
alerted by DHS officials that the
whipping narrative behind the infamous
horseback border patrol photos wasn't
true but at a press conference hours
later my orcus didn't stop or dispute
that
narrative this is just a taste of
secretary Marcus's misconduct however I
want to close by reminding everyone that
we're here today not only because House
Republicans are determined to hold
secretary Americus accountable but
because more than 200 house Democrats
voted on November the 13th to refer
articles of impeachment to our
committee we're now acting in a
bipartisan way I suppose in taking up
those very articles and I briefly want
to make it clear to the American people
secretary Marcus's refusal to follow the
law is sufficient grounds for
impeachment impeachment proceedings the
Constitutional history is overwhelmingly
clear on this subject the founders
designed impeachment not just to remove
officials engaged in criminal Behavior
but those guilty of such gross
incompetence that their conduct had
endangered their fellow Americans
betrayed the public trust or represented
a neglect of Duty according to one
scholar that there is and I quote a
settled understanding Beyond dispute
that impeachable offenses are not
limited to prosecutable crimes rather
the framers of the the Constitution
understood and the House of
Representatives has consistently
concluded that the impeachment power
reaches all manner of gross misconduct
in office that does serious harm to the
US political system the US
constitutional order or the people of
the country the actions policies and
statements of secretary Marcus easily
meet the standards end quote over the
next few hours you might hear a lot
about process and procedure and after a
thorough year-long investigation this
committee is following the Constitution
and procedure as directed by The house's
vote this past November make no mistake
attacks on the Integrity of the process
are meant to distract you from the
deadly consequences of our open border
unprecedented cartel control of our
Southwest border with record amounts of
fenel flooding across between ports of
entry and into our communities killing
tens of thousands of Americans every
year over 300 individuals on the
terrorist watch list apprehended
illegally crossing the Southwest border
since FY 2021 compared to just 14 from
FY 2017 to 2020 families devastated by
violent criminal aliens who have
committed murder rape and assault to say
nothing of the vehicular crimes
committed CBP and Ice Personnel losing
faith in their in their mission they and
their families bearing the brunt of this
Onslaught at the border the human costs
of this crisis are very real the dollar
costs of this crisis have been
astronomical as well New York City alone
projects that it will have have to spend
12 billion dealing with the flow of
illegal aliens into the City by 2025 and
it has even cutting the police force to
pay for it one County in Texas had to
cut salaries to afford B to afford
burials and Creations of illegal aliens
found dead in their jurisdiction these
costs will be felt for years to
come as I stated when we started this
investigation almost a year ago we will
follow the facts we have done just that
and the facts have led us here I look
forward to the testimonies of these
distinguished Attorneys General who have
watched this crisis play out unabated in
their states for the sake of our
homeland security and the well-being of
the people of the United States
Secretary mayorcas must be held
accountable I now recognize the ranking
member the gentleman from Mississippi Mr
Thompson for his opening
statement thank you very much Mr
chairman Mr chairman in April before
this Comm committee even began its
so-called impeachment inquiry chairman
green promised donors at a campaign
event that he'd bring an impeachment
case against Secretary of Homeland
Security Alejandro
meas according to a recording of his
comments obtained by the media the
chairman went on to tell those deep
pocket contributors to quote get the
popcorn and quote is going to be fun the
chairman may have thought that only
those in the campaign event would hear
his remarks but the truth has a way of
coming out his promised to a room full
of donors tell the American people all
they need to know about why Republicans
are hellbent on impeaching secretary
mayorcas the promise of impeachment was
made at a campaign event and shortly
afterwards Republicans began their
so-call
investigation into secretary mayorcas it
is now campaign season and Republicans
recently rolled out their impeachment
proceedings against secretary like a
pre-planned
predetermined political stunt it is this
is not a legitimate impeachment
Republicans want to throw political red
meat to their base and keep that
campaign Cash Coming they know they are
already a thin majority is slipping away
and think impeaching secretary mayorcas
even though there's absolutely no basis
for it will keep them in control of the
House Republicans certainly aren't going
to win votes based on their abysmal
legislative record this has been the
most unproductive dysfunctional Congress
in memory they kick their own speaker
out and then could agree on a new one
they paralyzed the house for weeks while
they fought among themselves they've
struggle to keep the government funding
and are continually on the verge of
shutting it down a member of their party
was expelled for lying about practically
everything in his life extreme Mega
Republicans have created this
impeachment circus Sideshow in part to
try to distract from their own failures
they took their sesh on the road
recently traveling to the border to
stand behind a Podium making canned
speeches and posing for photo ops but
for all their border security Bluster
Republicans oppos funding necessary to
secure the Border they tried to cut
money from Customs and Border Protection
personnel and have refused to take up
the president supplemental funding
requests chairman green himself recently
pinned an OP ED saying and I quote not
another dime to DHS unquote until the
Republican border bill is signed into
law even though he knows full well that
disastrous bill has absolutely zero
chance of being
enacted it should be Unthinkable that a
chairman of the committee own Homeland
Security would threatened to defund
DHS but that's exactly what happened
this is funding our Frontline border and
immigration agencies need to better
secure the Border Republicans have tried
to excuse their opposition to border
funding by claiming that border patrol
doesn't want more funding but that is
blatantly false in interviews with the
committee border patrol Chiefs
unequivocally supported more resources
Republicans know that they were in the
room and they have the transcripts but
let me refresh their memory Jason Owens
currently the chief of the border patrol
said we always need more agents Chief
Molin in Tucson an agency we need a lot
more a lot more people from Chief Hani
in San Diego we always need resources
and
Technology from Chief bino in El Central
the additional resources is the correct
technology assist with control of the
border and finally from Chief sez in El
Paso providing support for critical
positions and Resources by Congress
really does impact positively the
deployment of agents to the front line
every one of these Chiefs told the
committee that having more resources
would help them better secure the Border
Republicans go to the border and dress
pants and polo shirts to pose for
pictures but then leave the hardworking
agents in uniform and work boots behind
without the resources they ask for
Democrats want to give border agents
what they need to secure the border and
Republicans do not the truth is secur
ing the Border isn't really the
Republicans top concern if it was they'd
provide the people with boots on the
ground at the border what they need to
get the job done Republicans would
rather exploit a challenging policy
issue for their own preed political gain
Republicans disagree with the Biden
administration's border and immigration
policies they're angry that this
Administration won't take babies from
their moms or put kids in cages like the
last
Administration you cannot impeach a
cabinet secretary because you don't like
the president's policies let me say that
again you cannot impeach a cabinet
secretary because you don't like a
president's policies that's not what
impeachments for that's not what the
Constitution says Republicans are
willing to do grave damage to the
Constitution they claim to hold dear
fit them politically and in doing so
they are targeting secretary mayorcas a
public servant who spent his
distinguished 30-year career serving our
country as a federal prosecutor and in
leadership positions across the
Department of Homeland Security the
facts show secretary mayoras is doing
his job across the Department's many
critical Homeland Security missions
including border security and
immigration
enforcement despite what Republicans
would have Americans believe secretary
me orcus is enforcing immigration law
according to a recent analysis by the KO
Institute someone who crosses the border
under the current Administration is more
likely to be removed from the US than
someone who crossed under former
president Trump Republicans don't care
about that
this impeachment sham clearly is about
isn't about facts it's not about the law
it's about pure and simple politics just
look at those whose impeachment
resolutions have been referred to this
committee consider what kind of back
room deals Republican leadership must
have made with the most extreme Mega
members or as one Republican member
recently put it and I quote we we are
simply accommodating our least sensible
conference
members I certainly agree Democrats are
doing everything they can to hold the
line against Republican chaos Democrats
want to strengthen border security we
want to keep fenol off the streets we
want to keep communities safe this
circleid show impeachment does none of
that Mr chairman let's drop this
baseless impeachment and start doing the
real work of securing the Homeland for
the American
people before I yield back however Mr
chairman I have some parliamentary
inquiries you're recognized Mr chairman
isn't it true that there is no language
in either rule 10 or rule 11 that grants
the committee on homeland security
jurisdiction over the impeachment of any
Federal
Officer that is not a valid
parliamentary uh inquiry you need to
state the rule and how it relates to
this
proceeding uh that's why it's an inquiry
because I'm referencing either rule 10
or rule 11 that grants the committee of
Homeland Security jurisdiction or over
impeachment of any
officer there was a vote on the house
floor actually the motion made by the
Democrats to move impeachment articles
to this committee uh that trumps the
rules uh and it passed the house floor
and we are proceeding in accordance with
the demands the United States House of
Representatives by vote of the members
forther parliamentary inquiry gentleman
is recognized is a chair aware that of
the five resolutions impeaching
secretary mayorcas introduced in the
house so for this Congress just one
house resolution
863 has been referred to the committee
of Homeland Security and that four
others have been referred by the speaker
to the committee on J judiciary
again uh I need to know the rule that
you uh think this is in violation of so
it's not a um correct parliamentary
inquiry I I didn't I didn't understand
your your
ruling not a valid parliamentary
inquiry
further parliamentary inquir Mr gent
recognized would the chair inform the
committee of which rule our president
supports the idea that the motion to
refer overrides house rules on committed
jurisdiction particularly over a
constitutional matter that should have
been referred to the committee on
Judiciary it is that is not a valid
parliamentary
inquiry further parliamentary inquiry
gentleman is re recognized has the Full
House authorized this impeachment
inquiry such as it did on January 14th
1876 for the investigation of then
Secretary of War Willam W bellnap or
such as the house did on December 13
2023 for the investigation of President
Biden again not a valid parliamentary
inquiry the house of repres resentatives
voted to send this to this
committee further parliamentary inquiry
gentleman is recognized is a chair aware
that the committee on the Judiciary
adopted internal rules of procedure for
the conduct of its impeachment inquiry
of ex-president Trump in
2019 and does the chair intend to follow
suit and adopt additional committee
rules to ensure due process for
secretary mayorcas in this as yet
unauthorized inquiry again not a valid
parliamentary
inquiry uh further parliamentary inquir
gentleman is recognized and in reference
to secretary's right to do
process I have the following
parliamentary inquir Mr chairman does
the committee intend to follow the
secretary to be represented by Council
during these impeachment proceedings
the committee will follow the rules of
the house on that
measure so so do I understand that
Secretary of May orus will be allowed
counsel the committee will follow the
rules of the house on that for the
Parliamentary inquir gentleman is
recognized does a committee intend to
allow the secretary's councel to be
present at all hearings and
deposition the committee will follow the
rules of the house
additional inquire gentle the gentleman
is recognized does the committee intend
to allow the secretary's Council to
present evidence and object to the
admission of evidence the committee will
follow the rules of the
house is that a
no the committee will follow the rules
of the
house so do the rules allow that's
that's that's my point
we will follow the rules of the house as
they are written um and the question
isn't pertinent to this Committee
hearing
today well I
think we'll we'll get to that at some
point Mr chairman but I just want to go
on the record in pursuit of this is that
when former president Trump had
impeachment uh matters brought before uh
Senator Lindsey Graham made sure that he
was afforded counsel and questions and
everything and I'm just trying to make
sure that that we follow some kind of
order in
that as as I stated uh Mr ranking member
we will follow the rules of the house
all thank you um further parliamentary
inquir does a committee intend to allow
the secretary's counsel to call and
cross-examine
Witnesses again the committee will
follow the rules of the house further
parliamentary inquir gentleman is
recognized does the committee intend to
give the secretary's Council access to
and the ability to respond to the
evidence added by the committee the
committee will follow all of the rules
of the house thank you Mr chairman with
that I you back
thank you ranking member other members
of the committee are reminded that
opening statements may be submitted for
the record I'm pleased to have disting a
distinguished panel of witnesses before
us today and I ask that our Witnesses
please rise and raise their right
hand do you solemnly swear that the
testimony you will give before the
committee on homeland security of the
United States House of Representatives
will be the truth the whole truth truth
and nothing but the truth so help you
God let the record reflect that the
witnesses have answered in the
affirmative thank you please be
seated I would now like to formally
introduce our
Witnesses Mr kuden Austin canuteson was
sworn in as Montana's 25th Attorney
General on January the 4th 2021 prior to
that he was elected to the Montana House
of Representatives in 2010 from 2015 to
2019 he served as the speaker of the
Montana in a House of
Representatives gner Drummond was sworn
in as Oklahoma's 19th Attorney General
on January the 9th 2023 Mr Drummond's
law experience spans nearly 30 years and
includes Service as an assistant
district attorney and Pony and us how do
you pronounce it oage counties and as an
attorney in private practice Andrew
Bailey was sworn in as the 44th Attorney
General of the state of Missouri on
January the 3rd 2023 Mr Bailey is a
veteran of the United States
Army in which he served in combat as a
commissioned officer following the
terrorist attacks of September
11 Mr Frank Bowman is the University of
Missouri's curators distinguished
professor ameritus and Floyd R Gibson
Missouri endowed professor of law
ameritus at the University of Missouri
school of law he has also taught at
Georgetown University Law Center C
Washington and Lee University Gonzaga
University Indiana University's mckin
School of Law Wake Forest University and
the University of Denver and in Spring
of 2023 was visiting fellow at Oxford
University's roir American
Institute I thank all the witnesses for
being here today and I now recognize Mr
kinson for five minutes to summarize his
opening
statement thank you Mr chair chairman
members of the committee chairman green
ranking member
Thompson members of the distinguished
committee my name is Austin cansen
Montana attorney
general as the attorney general and
chief law enforcement officer for the
state of Montana I'm grateful for this
committee's attention to how secretary
Alejandro morcus failed leadership has
impacted States like Montana the
southern border certainly presents
difficult challenge for any
Administration but secretary mayorcas
and the Biden Administration have
absolutely poured gasoline on this
fire the southern border and the drugs
flowing across it into communities large
and small across our nation are
ultimately the reason that I am the
Attorney General of Montana
today I'm from rural Montana where I was
a private practice attorney until two
drug dealers sped past my kids' school
one shooting at the other out his
vehicle window in broad
daylight after that incident
I became our elected County prosecutor
where I saw what I thought were the
absolute worst things possible babies
born addicted to drugs kids thrown into
foster care because their parents would
rather buy drugs than take care of them
young girls sexually assaulted by family
members on
drugs people murdered over $20 drug
deals gone
wrong so to say that I was encouraged by
the previous administration's progress
in securing our nation's border is an
understatement
it's also an understatement to say that
I was horrified to see this
Administration under secretary mayorcas
leadership begin to erase that progress
and systematically dismantle policies
and programs meant to secure our
borders the most devastating impact of
the open border on Montana has been the
massive quantities of Mexican cartel
Fentanyl and
methamphetamine in 2020 drug task forces
in Montana seized
6,663 dosage units of fentanyl in 2021
the first year of secretary Marcus's
watch at the border that quantity
exploded
tfold to 61,000 dosage units of fentanyl
in 2022 Montana tripled that seizing
nearly
190,000 dosage units of cartel fenel the
numbers aren't finalized yet for 2023
but I can tell you that as of the third
quarter of 2023 Montana is on track to
have seized nearly a half million dosage
units of
Fentanyl and another 200 pounds of
meth and the cartels trafficked 100% of
that Fentanyl and meth across the
southern
Border in just one week during March
2022 17 people on the black feed Indian
Reservation overdosed on
fentanyl four of them died
I spoke with a woman later that Year
from the fort peek Indian Reservation
which is where I'm
from she was Raising her grandkids
because both of her sons were killed in
two separate fentanyl overdose
incidents Nationwide indigenous people
suffer the highest rate of fentanyl
overdoses in Montana the opioid overdose
death rate among Native Americans is
twice that of white
people the devastation of secretary
meorc refusal to Faithfully execute the
laws goes beyond the deaths that causes
and the anguished families left to pick
up pieces these drugs caus people to do
absolutely unspeakable
things a suspect in a current drug case
in Montana was taking delivery of drugs
that were being supplied directly from
the cartels in Mexico she kept her minor
daughter living in a yard
shed and allowed the man delivering
those drugs to sexually assault her
daughter as part of that drug
deal in another case last year a young
mother who was homeless was able to
finally find a bedroom in a house not
knowing that that room had been recently
occupied by a fental user shortly after
taking residence that mother found her
11-month-old child not
breathing fortunately medical and law
enforcement Personnel responded quickly
enough to administer the lock Zone
before the fentel from the prior
occupant killed that infant child
the Trump Administration overcame Fierce
opposition at every turn and was able to
gain control of our Southern border as
no previous administration could but all
of that progress has been
destroyed secretary mayorcas is the
architect of that destruction the
American people are watching they know
that our border was Secure just a few
years ago they see the devastation
metastasizing in our communities from
drugs and human trafficking the
conclusion is clear
secretary mayorcas has violated his oath
and I urge this body to impeach thank
you Mr chairman thank you mron I I now
recognize Mr Drummond for five minutes
to summarize his opening
statement good morning chairman green
ranking member Thompson and members of
the committee thank you for inviting me
to participate today in this hearing on
this critical issue I am gner Drummond
and I was elected Oklahoma's attorney
general in
2022 as the chief law enforcement
officer of Oklahoma it is my duty to
protect the people of my state I'm here
to testify about the dangers my citizens
face due to a porous border and the
failure of our federal government to
enforce its laws in the early evening of
November 20 2022 law enforcement
responded to a quadruple homicide after
a Chinese National allegedly entered a
garage on a 10 acre marijuana Farm in
rural
Oklahoma according to investigators the
as salent killed three men execution
Style with gunshots to the back of their
head and one woman with two shots to her
abdomen the Carnage of that day is but
one tragic example of a failed system
plagued plagued by failing leadership
throughout Oklahoma law enforcement
comes into contact daily with foreign
Nationals who have entered our country
illegally or who remain here illegally
or both this is all too common in
Oklahoma's illegal marijuana grow
operations
the voters of Oklahoma legalized medical
marijuana in 2018 while that
legalization led to the legitimate
cannbis business related businesses
throughout our state organized criminals
have overtaken the industry our law
enforcement Partners report that the
foreign Nationals most often involved in
these illegal Enterprises come from
China and Mexico the one thing these
criminals have in common is that they
have no regard for our laws or Public
Safety criminal illegal immigrants are
not content with growing only black
market marijuana they also produce and
distribute fentol and they engage in sex
trafficking and labor
trafficking Oklahoma's law enforcement
Community fights a constant battle
against these evils the Oklahoma Bureau
of Narcotics and dangerous drugs the
Oklahoma State Bureau of Investigation
and scores of local law enforcement
agencies deserve much praise for their
great and heroic efforts while there
have been many great success ESS is the
ongoing border crisis ensures a
NeverEnding flood of illegal foreign n
Nationals who continue to perpetrate
crimes that endanger our people when I
was sworn in as attorney general I
pledged to the people of my state that I
would do everything in my power to
protect them from these dangerous
criminals I petitioned our legislature
for greater resources and broader
authority to combat the threat they
responded with millions of dollars for
equipment and personnel and they granted
my office more power to fight this
criminal epidemic being fueled by our
border crisis in response I established
the organized crime task force the first
of its kind for Oklahoma and it is
needed primarily because Federal
officials have failed to enforce the
laws and to secure our border in the
short seven months since its creation
the organized crime task force has
investigated and is Prosecuting more
than 50 complex multi-jurisdictional
criminal cases the vast majority of
these cases involve Mexican or Chinese
drug syndicates these illegal foreign
actors burden my state with additional
costs that cannot be fully Quantified
for instance the Oklahoma Department of
Corrections reports that it is currently
housing more than 500 illegal immigrants
convicted of various violent crimes
before those criminal aliens were sent
to the Department of Corrections they
were in custody of our local jails which
have their own costs for housing
likewise there is a significant cost for
law enforcement in the investigating of
these crimes and for the prosecutors who
prosecute them the unsecure border
contributes to cost beyond the criminal
justice system as well while it is not
possible to ascertain the exact amount
of the costs it is easy to understand
the magnitude illegal immigration cost
Oklahoma taxpayers more than $750
million each year with a minimal offset
return Mr chairman members of the
committee I believe it is time for
accountability the people of Oklahoma
don't deserve to live under constant
threat from Criminal foreign Nationals
we don't deserve to have our communities
flooded with illegal drugs that were
smuggled across an unsecure border and
we don't deserve to have our loved ones
ripped away by those same drugs I ask
you to remember the people of Oklahoma
as you did liberate remember the murder
victims remember the drug overdose
victims and the families who mourn them
and of course please remember the law
enforcement officers who were lies every
day to protect us from it all thank you
thank you Mr Drummond I now recognize Mr
Bailey for five minutes to summarize his
opening
statement distinguished members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to appear before you this morning my
understanding of border security comes
from direct hands-on experience securing
a nation's border it was earned on a
Barren desert Battlefield half a world
away from the turret of an M2 Bradley
Fighting Vehicle in 2005 as a newly
minted second Lieutenant the United
States Army my platoon deployed to the
Nineveh Province Iraq under the command
of then Colonel HR McMaster was tasked
with securing the border between Iraq
and Syria our mission was simple close
the
border that's exactly what we did we did
not capture people and release them into
the interior of the country we did not
hand out citations and ask individuals
to report back in 10 years no we closed
the border to ensure the country was
safe since 20 21 more than 8 million
illegal immigrants have entered the
United States and that is more than the
population of my home state of Missouri
these numbers are not an accident there
is only one reason 8 million people
illegally cross a sovereign nation's
border because they know that they can
get away with it and why wouldn't they
in the last three years of secretary
Marcus's Reign there have been there has
been an orchestrated lack of enforcement
of our nation's immigration
laws he has failed to do that which is
most fundamental to his mission protect
our border that failure has not only led
to today's impeachment proceeding it has
given rise to an unprecedented level of
State actions necessary to fill the
vacuum created by the secretary's
refusal to do his job I'd like to
highlight for you a few of the actions
my office has taken as we fight to
secure the southern border one of those
is our fight to force him to finish
president Trump's border wall in an
interview last Wednesday on CNN
secretary mayorca stated we need
additional resources and we need them
now our lawsuit proves he already has
funding he just refuses to use it in
fiscal year 2020 Congress appropriated
funds explicitly for the purpose of
constructing barrier systems at our
Southern border to keep unauthorized
individuals out of our country in the
appropriation Congress will explicitly
stated the money shall only be available
for the construction of barrier systems
along the Southwest border secretary me
orcus and his administration refused to
comply with congress's command Missouri
immediately filed suit DHS attempted to
argue we did not have standing to
challenge its refusal to use the funds
but the the fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals ruled that states can in indeed
bring such a challenge that ruling
cleared the way for our lawsuit against
the secretary's refusal to finish
president Trump's border wall and it
allowed the lawsuit to move forward so
while we battle in court over secretary
M oris's refusal to use taxpayer dollars
in the manner Congress explicitly
prescribed we have little sympathy for
his pleas for more resources rather than
find ways to secure our border secretary
mayorcas has been busy enacting policies
to make it easier to enter our country
illegally we filed suit again against
May secretary mayoras for allowing
hundreds of thousands of illegal
immigrants to be paroled into the United
States every year parole allows
non-citizens to physically enter and
remain in the United States for up to
two years or even longer while their
application is reviewed without lawful
status we also filed suit to Halt
secretary Marcus's attempt to implement
a rule that redefined what had
previously been considered an illegal
border crossing as a lawful pathway
rather than acknowledge the root cause
of the influx of illegal immigrants
pouring over our border the secretary
tried to define the problem away by
simply making something that was once
illegal something legal without
Congressional
authorization mayor's process would
allow vast numbers of illegal immigrants
to enter the country and receive instant
work authorization under bogus Asylum
claims secretary marus has enacted
illegal policies that are akin to
posting a come in we open sign along the
southern border without taking
responsibility for the consequences of
his actions states are then forced to
Bear the enormous cost of secretary
Mor's failure
the states should not need to do the
federal government's job for them
secretary mayorcas swore oath to
Faithfully execute the laws of our land
in Missouri we remove officials who do
not do their jobs because we have seen
firsthand the catastrophic toll it takes
on entire communities my office was
forced to take action to remove a Soros
back prosecuting attorney from office
for her refusal to do her job that
resulted in The Killing and maming of
countless
missourians since we took action order
has been restored to the city of St
Louis it is rightful for Congress to
consider removing a government official
who refuses to do his job for the same
reason to restore order we have reached
a point of no return we're doing
everything we can at the state level to
rectify This Disaster but Congress has a
role to play for accountability while we
battle in the nation's courts Congress
must use every tool at its disposal to
obtain accountability for the American
people I thank the committee for its
time and welcome its
questions thank you uh Mr Bailey I now
recognize Mr Bowman for five minutes to
summarize his opening statement
chairman green ranking member Thompson
members of the committee I'm honored to
address this committee and I'm also
pleased to share the witness table with
three distinguished elected officials
one of whom immediately to my right Mr
Bailey I last remember seeing around
2011 as a seconde law student in my
evidence class at missou um as Attorney
General of Missouri He's Surely come up
in the world um congratulations to you
from an old Professor I on the other
hand remain simply an old
Professor I understand this to be the
first in a series of hearings on whether
constitutional grounds exist to impeach
Homeland Security secretary Alejandra
mayorcas the testimony so far has
focused on the performance of secretary
mayorcas and the Biden Administration
relating to immigration policy and
enforcement I'm not an IM an expert on
immigration policy I will not comment on
it here I have however been studying
constitutional standards for impeachment
for over 25 years I've written numerous
articles uh and a book on the history of
impeachment from its origins in England
in 1376 through the two impeachments of
President Trump my subject therefore
will be the Constitutional standard for
impeaching a cabinet officer the key
point about the about impeachment on our
constitution is that it is not supposed
to be a routine tool to resolve ordinary
public policy debates even very
passionate ones uh debates between
political parties or between one house
of Congress and the executive branch it
is instead a measure of Last Resort
reserved as one framer put it for great
and dangerous offenses in other words
for official misconduct which is
extraordinarily serious in degree and
critically of a type that corrupts or
subverts governmental processes or the
Constitutional order itself that the
framer's intended impeachment to be rare
is obvious from their decision that
conviction requires two-thirds of the
Senate that they intended to rule it out
as a weapon of ordinary political debate
is plain from how they defined
impeachable conduct the Constitution
provides that the president vice
president and all civil officers of the
United States shall be removed from
office on impeachment for and conviction
of treason bribery or other high crimes
and misdemeanors a cabinet secret
secretary is a civil officer subject to
impeachment but a cabet cabinet
secretary like the president is not
impeachable unless he's proven to have
committed treason bribery or other high
crimes and misdemeanors there's no
suggestion that I'm aware of that
secretary my mayorcas has committed
either treason or bribery hence any
article of impeachment against him must
establish that he committed High crimes
in misdemeanors the framers chose the
English parliamentary term of art High
crimes and misdemeanors rather than
other possible terms like
maladministration because they wanted a
flexible term that could reach
unanticipated new forms of grave
official misconduct but equally and
critically because they did not want an
impeachment that would be the equivalent
of a vote of no confidence in modern
parliamentary systems a vote that could
remove the president or other executive
branch officials between elections
whenever the legislature disapproved
approves of administration policy for
over two centuries students of the
Constitution have universally agreed in
the words of the great impeachment
scholar Charles Black that whatever may
be the grounds for impeachment and
removal dislike of a president's policy
is certainly not one of them to be
properly impeachable official conduct
must meet a very high threshold of
seriousness it must also be of a type
that corrupts and subverts the political
and governmental process and it ought to
be plainly wrong regardless of legal
technicalities the most commonly
encountered categories of impeachable
conduct are official corruption abuse of
power betrayal of the nation's foreign
policy interests and subversion of the
Constitution there is no serious
allegation of which I'm aware that the
secretary has done any of those things
now some might mischaracterize the
secretary's implementation of the
president's policy priorities as an
abuse of power but impeachable abuse of
power involves employing the powers of
off office for illegal or legit or
illegitimate ends particularly to gain
personal political or financial
advantage to benefit personal or
political allies or to injure political
or personal enemies and especially when
the abusive exercise of official power
undermines constitutional values
following the policy directives of one's
elected Superior in pursuit of that
superior's policy aims is simply not an
impeachable abuse of power finally
impeachment of a cabinet secretary over
policy agreements is not only contrary
to long-established constitutional
understanding but useless as a practical
matter if the official actions of the
officer are in accord with the
directives of his elected Superior the
president removing the secretary changes
nothing if members of this committee
disapprove of the Biden administration's
immigration and Border policies the
Congress give the Constitution gives
this Congress a wealth of legislative
powers to change them impeachment is not
one of those po
disagrees thank you Mr Bowman members
will be uh recognized by order of
seniority for their five minutes of
questioning an additional round of
questioning may be called after all
members have been recognize I now
recognize myself for five minutes of
questioning U this is for the three
Attorneys General do you believe that
secretary mayorcas has failed to enforce
or has subverted laws passed by the
United States Congress and we'll start
and go left to
right thank you Mr chairman yes yes or
no yes
sir he has failed to perform his duties
and is culpably inefficient has he
failed to enforce laws passed by the US
Congress he
has yes sir he is Secretary of morcus is
acting in violation of the law and in
violation of constitutional order by
negating congress's Appropriations
Authority and directives in the
Appropriations Bill and undermining the
rule of law by perverting the Plain text
of the statutes as it relates to the PE
process and its promulgation of the
circumvention rule thank you uh do you
believe that secretary Mar Arcus again
we're going to hit the three of you uh
do you believe that secretary Mar Arcus
has defied court orders issued by the
United States courts which I can cite if
you want me to but I'm sure you're
probably aware of them do you believe
that Secretary of mcus has defied court
orders issued by the courts federal
courts yes Mr
chairman
yes yes and it should never come to
having to go to court against secretary
mayorcas because he should be following
the laws enacted by this body thank you
uh in testimony to chip Roy before the
House of Representatives you saw some of
the video there the secretary said yes
to the question of whether DHS possessed
operational control of the Southwest
border is defined by the secure fence
act I might add act
meaning the constit or the Congress
passed it in subsequent testimony to the
Senate secretary Amer stated that no one
has ever had operational control of the
border and that he does not use that
definition of operational control as
defined by the secure fence act given
these statements do you believe that
secretary mayus misled Congress while
under oath in describing dhs's
operational control of the Border again
gentlemen the three of you yes Mr
chairman I do I believe the politic ized
his answer and failed to be
authentic yes
absolutely uh attorney general Merck
Garland acknowledged in testimony to the
United States Senate that drug cartels
were exploiting the current mayorcas
policies in order to traffic humans and
harmful drugs into the United States
Secretary meus on March 2823 stated that
he was unaware of this now we of course
informed him now armed with this
knowledge maricus continues the same
policies in fact doubling down with
newer policies that even exacerbate the
same horrible outcomes do you think
secretary mayorcas is doing this with
full knowledge that these cartels are
exploiting his policies Mr chairman
there's no doubt there is ample evidence
out there that human trafficking and
drug trafficking are increasing at an
exponential level at the southern border
yes Mr chairman based on my testimony
today and the facts are well knowed by
the secretary there's a porest border
that's feeding constantly at legal
actors in
Oklahoma M Bailey yes his unlawful
Behavior as it relates to the
circumvention rule and subversion of the
parole process exacerbate and encourage
the cartels and Seed control of the
border to the cartels in ways
unimaginable prior to these policy
positions thank
you where impeachment is concerned the
scale is very important how would you
describe the scale or comparable size of
this border crisis based on your law
enforcement experience and we'll start
Mr K thank you Mr chairman based on my
prior Prosecuting experience I can tell
you since 2020 the fentel and human
trafficking specifically well Fentanyl
and methamphetamine trafficking have
increased in my state there's no other
word than
meteoric I can tell you about the first
fentanyl case that I prosecuted in
2019 um that was a relatively small
amount for by today's standards but at
the time we thought that was a large
bust and again that was in 2019 our our
SE eure numbers from our various drug
task forces our V our various Federal
Partnerships bear that out categorically
fentanyl in Montana is by far our
largest public safety issue and it is
it's just exploded under this
Administration our seizure numbers bear
that out I'm I'm going to go ahead and
sort of interrupt my own question
because my time is running out I know Mr
Bowman mentioned the term great and
dangerous threat to the United States
I'll ask the last two of you do you feel
that the hundreds of thousands who've
died to fental overdose the crime that's
exponentially increased the uh increase
in Terrorist activity or you know
terrorists coming across the southern
border do you think it's great and
dangerous Mr D it is great and dangerous
we have Collision ball between Chinese
and Mexican cartels M Mr Bailey very
quickly yes absolutely uh the Missouri
State Highway Patrol a single law
enforcement agency in the state of
Missouri last year seized 12,500 grams
of fentanyl it's enough to kill every
Missourian I think thank you and uh I
yield I now recognize the ranking member
for his five minutes of questioning
thank you very much Mr chairman uh Mr
chairman I've been on this committee
since its Inception and have served as a
top Democrat since
2005 during that time Democrats and
Republicans have engaged in Spirited
debate over policy both uh with each
other and with various
administrations at the end of the day
however we always came together to make
the Homeland more secure for the
American people this has been our
committee's reputation and as a point of
Pride for me and all my Republican
counterparts uh from chairs and ranking
members today marks a dramatic shift
from the committee's record of sensible
bipartisan policymaking we used to come
together to resolve policy disputes but
now Republicans are trying to use the
awesome power of of impeachment instead
the Constitution doesn't let us do that
the constitution requires High crimes
and
misdemeanors Professor Bowman has
secretary mayorcas uh in your opinion
committed High crimes and misdemeanors
to meet that
requirement based on all the information
available to me I have not found any
indication that he's committed High
crimes and misdemeanors no
uh thank you over the weekend we
observed the 3D anniversary of the
January 6
Insurrection during which thousands of
angry Trump supporters who had whipped
into a frenzy by Donald Trump marched
from the White House to the Capitol to
obstruct the Democratic process and
let's be clear those individuals were
acting on the orders of Donald Trump who
told them quote we fight like hell and
and if you don't fight like hell you're
going to not have a country anymore
unquote that night most of us were
unified in our disgust over the attack
on the capital and the Democratic
process almost immediately however that
Unity eroded in the end only 10
Republicans voted to impeach Donald
Trump for engaging in high crimes and
misdemeanor
by inciting violence against the
government of the United
States Professor Bowman as a
constitutional expert would you agree
that inciting an Insurrection to
obstruct a peaceful transfer of power is
an impeachable
offense I do agree and I think it's
notable that not only did 10 members of
this body vote to impeach Donald Trump
but when the case went to trial in the
Senate uh seven Republican members of
the Senate voted for that precise
proposition there was indeed a majority
for convicting Mr Trump of high crimes
and misdemeanors albeit not the
two-thirds majority that was required
under the
Constitution and yet only 10 Republicans
uh voted to impeach Donald Trump for
conduct that is clearly an impeachable
offense but today Republicans are
attempting to impeach secretary mayorcas
where there are clearly no grounds Mr
chairman this impeachment is a sham and
the height of hypocrisy on the part of
my colleagues across the aisle I urge
Republicans to put politics aside and
get back to the work for the American
people i y
back the gentleman Yi I now recognize
the gentleman from Texas the chairman of
the Foreign Affairs committee Mr McCall
thank you Mr chairman uh this this is a
Solem U occasion uh probably the most
serious obligation we have uh in this
committee on this committee the last
time a Cabinet member was impeached was
during the administration of ulyses
srant uh many years ago in my experience
so as a deputy attorney general for
criminal justice state of Texas is a
federal prosecutor charged with
counterterrorism and National Security
uh and as chairman of this very
committee I've never seen this border
more out of
control myarc has took an oath to
support and defend the Constitution of
the United States in my judgment he has
violated that oath federal law provides
a government detain and remove aliens
convicted of crimes and those who are
issued removal orders by immigration
courts this is very issue that my state
took up on appeal to the Supreme Court
he has violated this on day one he res
sended remain and Mexico migrant
protection protocol direct cause and
effect opening the
floodgates I marked that provision up on
my committee Foreign Affairs it's now
part of
hr2 but he took that power away from his
law enforcement officers and I have to
quote I don't quote former Texas
congresswoman Barbara Jordan very often
but she said quote for the system to be
credible people actually have to be
deported at the end of the process and
let's look at the numbers they speak for
themselves 8 million encounters under
this Administration 2.3 aliens in the
interior of the United States with no
legal status enough to fill up 13
states just last month we had over
300,000 trying to get into the United
States over 300 on the terror watch list
have gotten into the United States when
I chaired this committee that was a a
big red flag and the FBI director said
so and he testified as well over 200,000
Americans have died from fentel I
personally went to a funeral last
Saturday one of my children's friends
died from Xanax Rel with
fentel 200,000 Americans that's more
than triple the number of Americans who
died in the Vietnam War to put that into
perspective the secretary has an
embolden a criminal Enterprise and the
biggest human trafficking scheme in my
lifetime he terminated MPP Chief Ortiz
noted that had a direct cause and effect
and when marus went down to the Border
they turned their backs on him because
quote sir you have turned your back on
us my state has spent almost 14
billion just uh this
cycle we've allocated 9.6 billion to
operation loone star my Governor bust
illegals to San uary cities and states
around the country to Showcase what we
are experiencing and you are as well in
your States every single day and the
damage was clear the Supreme Court did
note the damage but said that that this
had to be resolved outside the courts in
other words they said that Congress had
to address this either through
Appropriations oversight and in Sam
ELO's decision yes through impeachment
this is a legal justification for these
proceedings the founders believed
impeachable offenses included corrupt
Administration neglect of Duty and
official misconduct at the
Constitutional Convention they said this
Alexander Hamilton asserted abuse or
violation of public trust was
impeachable justice story Supreme Court
public office is a public trust and a
violation of public trust is sufficient
I find this to be a profound violation
of public trust Alexander Hamilton
stated in Federal's paper 65 the
subjects of impeachment are a nature
which may be denounced political as they
relate chiefly to injuries done
immediately to society itself my God
what about the injuries done to society
that we've seen to our three illustrious
Attorneys General please tell me the
injuries done to your societies back
home and do you think this secretary
merits and that impeachment is warranted
in this
case thank you representative um I think
the most powerful statistic I can give
you from my state is our confirmed State
Crime Lab fentanyl overdose death rate
since 2019 Montana's confirmed fentanyl
overdose deaths have increased
1700% Congressman I think that is the
absolute strongest indicator we know
where these drugs are coming from it's
not a political statement of mine it's
not an opinion of mine to say that 100%
of that fentanyl came from the Mexican
drug cartels we know that to be true we
get that from our federal Partners in
the DEA we get that from all of our drug
task forces all all the law enforcement
agencies that are under my purview and
just real quickly General Drummond and
and Bailey just very
quickly we have witnessed a a mass
collusion between Chinese Nationals
coming through the southern Border in
concert with Mexican
cartels 1,500 fentel deaths 43 children
dead from accidental poisoning from
exposure to Fel $114 million born by
taxpayers and increased healthcare costs
thank you I yield back the gentleman
yields I now recognize uh Miss Sheila
Jackson Lee of Texas the gentle lady
from Texas for her five minutes of
questioning
Mr chairman I thank you for
yielding I almost don't know where to
start and certainly will find the five
minutes to be underwhelming in terms of
the time that I
need I do want to uh express my solity
and humbleness and expression of
appreciation for having the honor of
serving on this committee even in the
midst of the horrific
911 it seems that this committee always
Rises to the occasion to be the problem
solvers and I clearly am someone who has
lived the immigration Story coming from
Texas and I would certainly have a
different view than my friend and
colleague who has just spoken about the
actions that have been taken as children
and families have been
manipulated as if they are
inhuman I do think that one of the
highest callings of this committee is in
fact to do the bidding of solving the
nation's immigration problems and as a
member of the Judiciary Committee I have
over the years introduced comprehensive
immigration reform legislation year
after year after year and so I am
certainly willing and able to be part of
the solution for the three attorney
generals of which I am an Al lawyer
certainly served in uh capacities to
realize the important work that you do
but I must join in the sadness of this
day uh the sadness of this day because
it is not constitutionally grounded it
is not constitutionally sound it is not
going to save any lives uh at all and
there is nothing that you have put
forward today that evidences uh in any
way uh a impeachable offense by
secretary myar is the first imigrant to
serve in this position a dislike of the
president's policy is not is not a basis
for impeachment the basis for
impeachment is corruption abuse of power
betrayal of the nation
and that is of course
allegations you as Witnesses I am sorry
to say Mr chairman have borne no
testimony that indicates that secretary
Marcus has done any of
that so I thank the ranking member for
his earlier eloquent words on this
shameful fraudulent impeachment inquiry
where we are not fixing the immigration
issues that my constituents in Houston
need at the onset I'm reminded of the
words of the representative Barbara
Jordan complete difference from what I
heard her quoted before I know that she
did an excellent job in trying to frame
the immigration issues of years past my
predecessor represented Houston like I
do she endorsed me glad to say a mentor
like her my faith in the constitution is
whole it is complete it is total and I'm
not going to sit here and be an idle
spectator of the dimunition the
subversion the destruction of the
Constitution because the Constitution
said to create a more perfect union to
instill Justice that is what this
inquiry is a demun a subversion and a
destruction of the Constitution of the
United States I cannot stand for that Mr
chairman impeachment is one of the
absolute Powers Congress has to ensure
against an executive might as James
Madison explained at the Constitutional
Convention quote pervert his
administration into a scheme of
speculation or oppression the men
present in Philadelphia some 23 six
years ago were deliberate they were
intentional they were exacting in their
draft of the Constitution that has
guided us
forever these are their words and the
words of our constitution the legal
standard by which we have solemnly
consider whether to exercise this
extraordinary power Article 2 Section 4
guides and I quote the president vice
president and all civil officers of the
United States shall be removed from
office on impeachment for the for the
conviction of treason bribery or other
high crimes and misdemeanor that is
outstanding treason bribery High crimes
and misdemeanor Professor Bowman in your
review of the cons of Congressman uh
Green's impeachment resolution which
referred to this committee and in your
review of the various reports by
committee Republicans have you
identified any actions by secretary
mycus that reach the Constitutional
threshold of impeachment treason Bary
other H crimes and misdemeanors
professor
no in all of the reports have you seen
any evidence of such the reports you've
been able to secure or the reports that
I brought your attention to I've seen
lots of reports about arguments about
policy I've seen nothing that rises the
level of an impeachable offense and so
Mr chairman the Constitution is to be
our guide we must end this political
stunt that seeks to impeach an office of
the United States because an extremist
minority of the House of Representatives
does not agree with the policies of this
president or that he carries out let's
work with these attorney generals to
solve the real problems to not
incarcerate children to separate them
from their family treason bribery and
other high crimes and misdemeanors is
our legal standard it is clear that is
the basis from which we must proceed
that is the Constitutional bar you have
failed to reach we created this book as
they say to create a more perfect union
and to establish justice gentlemen you
have law degrees and have taken an oath
as I have and you've taken an oath to
procure the rights of your citizens
please sit with us to establish justice
for all of America for the work you do
and for those who come to seek a better
life however they come we may perceive
in a different light but let us do it in
perceiving Justice you hurt me you hurt
my heart you hurt what Barbara Jordan
stood for you diminish this book and
these words by sitting here today to
suggest that sec JY Arcus must be in
fact impeached because of policies that
we disagree with may God continue to
guide us in our work so that we can do
what we have been assigned to do with
that I yield back gentle lady Ys I now
recognize Mr Higgins the gentleman from
Louisiana and the chair of the
subcommittee on on the
border thank you Mr
chairman my my
my Mr moment I wasn't even going to ask
you any questions today but I'm going to
give you an opportunity to clarify the
for record and I do believe that
according to your resume you're a
professor of constitutional law sir is
that
correct I am an Emeritus professor at
the Missouri okay School of Law you're a
smart guy you got alphabet behind your
name on your business card
so is it your position that you're
taking today as a Democrat
witness that the that the founders
intent with the term High crimes and
misdemeanor was designed to restrict the
power of impeachment to a violation of
specific written statute is that your
position we're
listening yes and and that is your
position okay and you're excuse me
excuse me Congressman you said yes it's
a simple question no I'm gonna I'm going
to move on the excuse me Congressman it
clearly was not reclaiming my time it
clearly was not the intention of the
founders to limit the power of
congressional
impeachment over the Executive
Branch to to limit that to violation of
written statute that's quite correct
Congressman I've written extensively
thank but you just
said you just said something endeav but
that's all right we appreciate you being
here today Mr Bowman and representing
uh University of
Missouri sure it's a wonderful law
school on this committee we've carried
out our investigation secretary may
orcus I sit here today tell you we're
going to impeach him he's going to be
impeached and he should be he is the
executive in charge of the Border policy
for for President Biden now President
Biden has the right as a chief executive
to
hire men that that that don't have the
skill and then figure that out down the
line and replace them President Biden
also has a right as a chief executive to
have wild policy in
mind but H but the
executive that sits on his cabinet
that's in charge of
actually enforcing those policies that
has the law enforcement experience to
know when those policies are going to
bring injury upon our country that
executive has a
responsibility to advise the president
that his policies are not only not
working to secure the
Border they're actually bringing injury
Upon Our
Country United States
Constitution is is the law of the land
that we swear our oath
to secretary mayorcas has brought
generational trauma Upon Our
Country hundreds of thousands of
American lives destroyed hundreds of
thousands dead millions and millions
wave upon wave of human misery coming
across our Southern border we're losing
our country down there my God my
colleagues you've got to recognize this
we've got to stop this arterial bleed
it's not about money we spent less money
in 2019 than we did in 23 a lot less
through DHS and we had the border under
control it's policy that has changed and
who is driving that policy secretary
mayorcas so who shall be
impeached quite rightfully
so secretary
mayorcas Mr
nudson from your position sir and I'm
sorry for what your you and your people
and your community and your state are
going through sir on behalf of this
Congress that has been unable to take
action as of
yet I'm sorry for what you're going
through do you
concur with the things that I've spoke
on and shared I absolutely do concur
Congressman I think this body is
completely within its constitutional
legal right to bring impeachment
proceedings here Mr
Drummond I also
concur Mr Bailey I concur the
secretary's abdicated His official
duties he's in dereliction of Duty and
should be held
accountable I appreciate all the
panelists for being here today I thank
the chairman for his leadership on this
issue he has been calm and patient and
Jud ious in our procedure we have laid
out the case for the impeachment of
secretary mayorcas we have promised the
American people we would fulfill that
somber Duty and we shall Mr chairman I
yield the gentleman yons I now recognize
Mr Payne the gentleman from New Jersey
for his five minutes a
question thank you Mr
chairman
well today's
hearing would be a
joke and and let me
just put something out here with in
reference to
fentol it it is something that
is is really damaging our country our
young people
obviously but I remember in the
1980s when the crack epidemic
was
prevalent
um the first lady Nancy
Reagan told folks you know just say
no so I think we need to incorporate
that into this
epidemic why is fentol killing so many
of our
folks because they're consuming in
it we have to look at the demand for
it as well we know we have a problem in
stopping it and we are all hellbent in
doing
that but we
also have to look at the
demand or as Nancy Reagan said just say
no but back to the
Topic at at hand uh as I stated this
would be a joke if the stakes weren't so
high and serious for the reasons laid
out by my friend M Jackson Lee I'm
embarrassed for my Republican colleagues
they pretend that their fraudulent
impeachment against secretary marus is
about high crimes and
misdemeanors that's because they know
well as we do that this is this
so-called impeachment is nothing more
than an extremist Maga takeover of the
committee in this
Congress just look at just look at who
is in um the driver's seat of this
fraudulent
impeachment it's not the chairman of the
committee it's not even the subcommittee
chair it's an extreme maggot back
venture who proverbially speak
shoved her leadership out of the
driver's seat and now has the Reigns of
the Congress and about ready to drive us
all off the
cliff chairman can Proclaim that he has
led this yearlong investigation into
secretary Marcus leadership that led to
today's proceedings but we all know that
this is
false we are here because a member of
Cong Congress who believes the
anti-semitic conspiracy that Jewish
space lasers coming down to earth caused
the deadly wildfires in California in
2018 someone who has called black people
like me slaves to the Democratic party a
woman who believes serving this great
country in the military is throwing your
life away someone who supports
insurrections who tried to destroy
American democracy who wants to defund
the FBI and someone who mocked survivors
of a traic school tragic school shooting
a member of Congress who truly all who
believes all that is brought us here it
is not chairman Green's impeachment
resolution that was referred to this is
committee to this
committee chairman green has not even
introduced an impeachment
resolution and it is not chairman green
so-called investigation into secretary
morcus that got us here we had an
impeachment resolution before us weeks
before the Chairman's alleged in
investigation even
concluded Professor Bulman do mere
policy disputes between members of
Congress and a cabinet secretary
constitute impeachable High crimes and
misdemeanors Congressman they do not I
think the conclusion is universal among
those who have studied this question has
been so since since the time of the
founding that policy differences no
matter how severe no matter how heated
um are simply not grounds for
impeachment thank you Mr chairman I'd
like to request unas consent to submit
an article from CBS News titled margerie
Taylor green backs off forcing vote on
second Alejandra May orcus impeachment
resolution dated November 30th
2023 without objection so ordered in
which representative green is quoted as
saying we need to do this we need to
move forward so I got guarantees so we
will move forward with impeachment and
with that I yield back the gentleman
yields I now recognize the gentleman
from North Carolina uh Mr Bishop for his
five minutes
question Mr Bowman I it it strikes
me how much your opinion has changed in
just a few years I I was pointed out
that in your 2019 book entitled High
crimes and misdemeanors a history of
impeachment for the age of
trump uh you have this passage no
Congress since that time referring to
the impeachment of belnap the uh
cabinet person that that Grant had
dismissed before his impeachment but you
say no Congress since that time has
either moved fast enough or thought it
worthwhile to actually impeach a
subordinate executive branch official
neverthe nonetheless the latent power to
do so remains important and here's the
key sentence not only is it useful as a
signal of legislative displeasure with
Administration personnel and policy but
the undoubted authority of Congress to
impeach subordinate officials carries
with it the associated powers of the
house to investigate potentially
impeachable conduct and of the Senate to
try the allegations In Articles of
impeachment now frankly sir I agree with
you more today and not
then um that is to say I don't think
pure policy differences is the basis for
an
impeachment neither is that what's
happening here it is exceedingly apt for
that reason that the majority Witnesses
are three State Attorneys General
gentlemen I look forward to joining you
in
2025 but let me point this out a lot of
people would say well American people
are interested in hearing something
about a legal case I think they might
be last
June two of your colleagues in Texas and
in Louisiana had sued secretary my orcus
saying that guidelines that he issued to
his
Department
blatantly violated commands of Congress
in statute to
detain any Criminal Who had committed
certain crimes and was and was released
from State
custody were required the Attorney
General then the Secretary of Homeland
Security later by amendment required to
detain such persons until they were
deported and persons subject to a
permanent order a final order of
deportation required to be
detained contrary to that order
secretary my orcus dismantled the
detainer
process
completely he said he said that that was
going to be subject to discretion only
in cases where the department or he
deems it to in imperil our national
security or security from additional
crime would it be
done Attorneys General Su and here's
what the Supreme Court said you don't
have
standing we can't hear from you we can't
settle
this here's what Alito said in
descent the Congress to put the point
simply Congress enacted a law that
requires the apprehension and Detention
of certain illegal aliens whose release
it thought would endanger Public Safety
the Secretary of DHS does not agree with
that categorical requirement he prefers
a more flexible policy and the Court's
answer today is that the executive's
policy Choice prevails unless Congress
by withholding funds refusing to confirm
presidential nominees threatening
impeachment and removal Etc can win a
test of
strength in other words the Alo in
defense went on and
said I don't think this is a wise
decision for us to make but that is the
decision the majority
made that if you want the law to be
followed you're going to have to impeach
somebody you're going to have to as
Justice Alo said the Congress is going
to have to go to war with the
executive Mr
kudon what about that isn't that right
isn't that what the Congress is put to
to decide whether to do our duty as the
Supreme Court has said we can't do it
it's up to the Congress and you guys
have been have tried to do it you've
succeeded in other areas you're
continuing to Sue and you're succeeding
Florida has enjoyed some practices I
think the Supreme Court just just
granted an
emergency uh relief from the DHS cutting
Texas border barrier what about that Mr
kudon I didn't leave you a lot of time
but I'm sure you can add more wisdom in
30 seconds than I did into it I'll be
brief Congressman uh thank you for the
question yes I absolutely agree not only
with Justice alto's descent but the I
would point out also in that case that
the majority also pointed out uh to your
point that Congress possesses an array
of tools to analyze and influence those
policies and those are political checks
for the political process that's exactly
what you're dealing with here you folks
have got an executive versus legislative
branch War
here so much of this Mr chairman isn't
about even policy discretion that's
granted to the ad Administration it is
about Square violations of Law and they
will either be they cannot be remedied
in court they will either be dealt with
by this Congress to vindicate the rule
of law or we will surrender rule of law
to a rule of man I yield the gentleman
yields I now recognize chairman Mr
chairman point of order point of order
the point of order you're recognized uh
I think we all heard the colleague say
he's running for another office but that
violates the rule
23 uh and and I won't ask that it be
taken down I just ask that if he's going
to run just go run just don't run when
the committee is in session gentleman uh
has made his point of order and I now
recognize Mr swell the gentleman from
California and our ranking member on
cyber security subcommittee for his five
minutes of questioning I want to thank
the Attorneys General for participating
uh today thank you for your service to
your States I was a prosecutor before
coming to Congress I missed that job uh
my father was a cop my brothers are cops
and it seems like we've got a pretty
educated group of Attorneys General here
Mr canuteson uh you went to Montana law
school
right yes representative pretty good Law
School uh Mr Bailey uh University of
Missouri is that right yes and you
served our country after September 11 as
well thank you for doing that uh Mr
Drummond uh you went to Georgetown is
that right I did that's a good school I
was rejected there twice uh for law
school and then as a transfer uh that's
a very good school um I just want to
level set where we all are on what's a
crime what's not a crime because uh the
three of you have offered testimony to
my Republican colleagues about what is
an impeachable offense and I just want
to go down the list here of some of the
potential impeachable offenses uh that
we've seen in in the history of the
Congress uh bribery Mr canuteson would
you agree that's an impeachable
offense I would Congressman Mr drumman
would you agree bribery is an
impeachable offense I would and uh Mr
Bailey would you do you agree briberies
is and impeachable offense yes same as
extortion Mr
kudon yes Mr Drummond extortion yes Mr
Bailey yes how about obstruction of
justice would you agree that that's an
impeachable offense Mr Canon uh if there
was a conviction yes okay Mr Drummond
yes and Mr Bley yes how about inciting
violence against police officers uh what
would you say Mr K again if there was a
conviction of a criminal offense I think
that was certainly rise to the level and
Mr drumond how about incitement of
violence yes and Mr Bailey incitement of
violence would need more facts to make
that legal determination I think that's
a bar of sufficient facts and Mr Kus I
just want to drill down a little bit
because you said if there was a
conviction um so are you saying that Mr
Mya should be convicted criminally
before he could be
impeached Congressman no I'm simply
speaking to your example of would
inciting violence against a police
officer rise to the level of an
impeachable offense I I'm my testimony
was if there was a conviction for that
crime then yes okay and and obstruction
of justice you said the same thing right
correct but you think for Mr mycus he
does not need a conviction to be
impeached well as this body has done in
its past I think there's certainly
precedent no I do not believe there has
to be a criminal offense High crimes and
misdemeanors as it was understood by the
founders as it was understood in the
English common law does not necessarily
mean there has to be an actual crime
committed in the summer 2019 former
president Donald Trump used $300 million
of taxpayer dollars to ask president
zalinsky of Ukraine to get dirt on his
potential uh primary political opponent
uh Joe Biden uh and he was uh impeached
in the house uh for that should he have
been impeached for that Mr
canson Mr chairman I'm excuse me Mr
chairman representative I'm not a member
of this Congress I'm not privy to all
that information I I certainly haven't
seen a lot of those reports uh this body
chose to go forward with those
proceedings as is its purview Mr drumond
it's outside my Lane I'm just the simple
attorney general from Oklahoma Mr Bailey
I believe President Trump was acquitted
of all charges and that's beyond the
purview of my testimony today on January
6 he incited and aimed a violent mob at
the capital uh six police officers would
later lose their lives uh one lost a
finger one lost an eye the president was
uh impeached 10 Republicans voted for
that impeachment uh Mr cansen should he
have been impeached for that yes or
no Mr chairman representative he
was okay Mr drumman he he was impeached
for that and should he have
been I I don't have an opinion on that
issue okay Mr Bailey what do you think
about that he was acquitted of those
charges okay so what's interesting to me
again I respect that you all are here is
that when you've testified to Mr
Marcus's conduct and you believe pretty
clearly that he can be impeached for his
conduct but when we go through pretty
egregious conduct of using taxpayer
dollars of inciting and aiming a mob
having the greatest attack ever on this
Congress this Capital our constitution
you don't want to comment on it at all
and I I think what we're really seeing
from the majority in all of this is that
they're not interested in finding any
solution On the Border in fact what we
have seen is that there's a 2014 deal in
the Senate bipartisan they walked away
when they were in the majority speaker
Johnson has said that he will refuse any
additional funding for the border and
and now we have witnesses who again want
to comment only on MAR orcus but don't
want to comment on President Trump Mr
chairman respectfully I just see a party
that
wants that does not want to fix but only
wants the fiction uh and with that I'll
yield back gentleman yields I now
recognize the gentleman from Florida Mr
Jimenez for his five minutes of
questioning thank you thank you very
much and I was fascinated by my my
colleagues um you know questioning line
of questioning um somewhere I was going
to go to maybe not as quite as
eloquently as him I'm not running for
attorney general or anything
um Mr Bowman um you say in your
testimony written testimony and some the
foundational requirements for
impeachable high crimes and misdemeanors
is that they must be
extraordinarily seriousness and and
ought to be of the type that corrupts or
subverts governmental processes or the
Constitutional order and I find that you
know I I I I underlined that
specifically because I wanted to ask you
do you believe that the that the death
of 200,000 Americans from fentanyl
overdose is that is that extraordinarily
serious it's certainly an a serious
matter and one that has to be addressed
by this body by exercising its
constitutional legislative powers to
work with the leg with the executive
branch um to address the policy the
problem that you have that you're
confronting here that's that's that's
that's good I'm gonna I'm gonna reclaim
my time now that you've answered the
question thank you very much okay and
then and it ought to be of the type that
corrupts or subverts governmental
processes or the Constitutional order
now you know I'm not a con you know I'm
not a constitutional scholar Etc but I
do believe that the the the Constitution
is set up to have three distinct
branches of government you have
legislative you have judicial and and
you have the administrative branch and
and the founding fathers wanted a
balance of power is that is that what
you get from the from the Constitution
and the founding fathers what they
wanted to do the balance of
power Mr Bowman indeed okay and so the
it's it's up to the legislative branch
to actually create the
laws and the will of Congress is
supposed to be then carried out by the
administrative branch is am I off on
that or is that what the founding
fathers thought should have
happened in general yes okay and so we
have this issue of policy versus law and
and if I read if I get you right you
believe that this is a question of
policy but I don't believe it's a
question of policy I believe it's
actually a question of violating the law
the law clearly states that people
coming into the United States or or
people seeking asylum in the United
States two things happen to them they're
either detained by here country or
they're they're detained in another
country waiting the outcome of their of
their Asylum hearing that's what law
says um the law also says that the the
executive branch actually has the right
to parole but on a caseby casee basis
not mass mass mass uh parole and so the
the mayorcas administration the Biden
mayorcas Administration is actually
violating both they're they're not
detaining people coming in or they're
they're not keeping them in a third
country and they're not detaining the
United States and they're also allowing
mass m Mass parole which violates the
clear intent of Congress is it your
opinion that the only that that this is
a policy issue and that the the uh the
Biden Administration has the right to
clearly subvert the will of
Congress my opinion congressman is that
disputes over the exercise of discretion
by the secret AR um are difficult
they're being resolved in the courts um
and I must say that those disputes have
not yet been finalized indeed the only
cases involving those disputes that have
made it up the Supreme Court have
resulted in rulings in in favor of the
secretary and of the president
essentially this is an ongoing legal and
policy dispute um and it is it is not
therefore the kind of thing for which uh
impeachment should be used well I I
believe that you know that we are at a
Crossroads here because I do believe
that uh we Congress have given way too
much leeway to to the administrative
Branch if that's the case this is
clearly the intent of of of Congress was
uh people coming to the Border need to
either stay in a in another country or
they need to be detained and it clearly
was that parole was to be done on a
case-by Case basis now I don't believe
that there's an issue of policy it's an
issue of violating the law and that
violation of the law is actually caused
has actually led to mass suffering in
the United States uh 200,000 Americans
dying because of fentanyl overdose and I
disagree with my with my colleague on
the other side that says it's a question
of of voluntarily stopping using drugs
actually Mo a lot of these deaths are
caused by people don't even know they're
taking fentanyl they're thinking they're
taking something else uh and it's laced
with fentanyl uh and so you know if if
it's it's we're down of that where every
single time that there is a that that
the administration decides to violate
the law that we have to impeach somebody
I guess then we we need to impeach
somebody and so with that uh you know I
yield my time back the gentleman Ys I
now recognize a gentleman from
California Mr CA thank you Mr chairman
and I kind of agree with Mr godinas and
some of the comments he made um before I
get into my uh presentation like to
present a uh article submitted for the
record titled 20 through 2023 year in
review secretary mayorca Champions
Department wide efforts to save lives
and prepare for the 21st Century
Security challenges without objection so
moved and I want to thank our Witnesses
for being here today I'm glad you're
here talking about those things that are
important you spoke passionately about
fenol the damage that's caused to our
communities I'm with you on that one
back home on Main Street a lot of deaths
a lot of pain because of
fentol my investigation of this issue
90% of fentol more like
95% comes through our ports of entry and
65% comes through one Port of Entry the
sedra Port of Entry and most of that the
majority vast majority is smuggled by
American citizens and green card
holders that's why I support additional
fund
for our ports of Entry technology more
Personnel more drug sniffing dogs more
technology and Mr chair again I want to
thank you for holding this hearing
because Homeland Security is an
important issue for all Americans for
this nation so let's look at the facts
here
today let's be clear about what we're
looking at today on a worldwide
basis some of the Nations that are
dealing with this what I would call
worldwide refugee challenge United
States Europe Germany Italy Greece
Colombia Colombia is holding 3 million
Venezuelan refugees right now Costa
ricaa Mexico these are among some of the
Nations looking at this Refugee
challenge let's go let's look at some of
the causes of this migratory
pattern
covid-19 and secretary mayorcas did not
bring up
covid-19 Co you know secretary mayorcas
is also not responsible for the
robberies gang violence
extortions in Central America and
secretary mayoras is also not
responsible for the government collapse
and violence in Haiti he's also not
responsible for the challenges the
economic collapse in Venezuela secretary
myus is also not responsible for the
human rights violations economic
collapse in Cuba he's also not
responsible for the economic collapse
human rights violations in
Nicaragua Peru Ecuador the invasion of
Russia of
Ukraine the economic collapse going on
in China today secretary myurus is not
responsible for these things to the cont
he's working to manage the challenge and
provide Frontline officers with the
resources that they
need even Senate Republicans get it
Senate Republicans are working with
Democrats right now and the White House
to try to address these challenges so in
the last minute and a half that I have
I'm going to ask Professor
Bowman is secretary in mycus executing
the law the full extent of his abilities
with the limited resources Congress has
given him is this an impeachable offense
sir no sir it is not and I should point
out also in addition it's critical to
note that if we could impeach cabinet
officers or presidents for that matter
anytime there are legal disputes about
the application of the law or their
exercise of discretion then every
president and every cabinet officer
would be impeachable in the previous
administration that of Mr Trump there
were repeated lawsuits against Mr
Trump's immigration policy um some of
which he won some of which he lost if
the mere presence of heated legal
disagreements about the legitimacy of
presidential immigration policy were
impeach impeachable Mr Trump would have
been impeached for a third time to do
such a thing would be profoundly
anti-constitutional and profound
profound disruption of the
Constitutional separation Powers so sir
are we looking essentially at political
public
policy debate here as opposed to an
impeachable
offense that's certainly my
interpretation Congressman thank you
very much Mr chairman M you Mr chairman
have a unanimous consent motion here do
you want to do it now or wait till your
turn I'll do it now if I could okay I
want to introduce the January 10th um
2024 Washington Post article where the
chairman has quoted as saying that our
investigation made clear that this
crisis Finds Its foundation and
secretary mayor's decision making and
Congressman Norman talks about needing
to impeach my orcus because of quote bad
judgment okay uh with no
um disc consent or disagreement we'll
admit it to the record now I recognize
Mr fluger the gentleman from Texas for
his five minutes of questioning thank
you Mr chairman it's sad that we're here
sad that we're in this position earlier
um it was said that this is not a
legitimate impeachment I I guess that's
something Democrats know a little bit
about uh and our witness just talked
about um the impeachment of Mr Trump so
I disagree with that and I really I take
no pleasure in the significance of this
effort I've wrestled with the
appropriate constitutional response to
what has become a complete failure to
enforce the law to adhere to
Congressional directives to secure the
home land the and the failure to secure
the Homeland has been so
significant so catastrophic that
Congress must use its power to provide
accountability we must be the check and
the balance against such an extremely
egregious breach of public trust and
that's what this is and if not this
effort then I ask my Democrat colleagues
what effort where is your answer to
accountability where
is your article one authorities to check
the the the executive branch will the
gentleman yield to answer the question
no the answer from the other side simply
cannot be that we're
powerless and I asked rhetorically if
not this effort then how do we hold this
failure and you'll have your chance to
to wax poetic on that let's just go
through the numbers fiscal 23 27,000
pounds of fenel was seized that's that's
what was seized that's not all that
entered this country Mr chairman the
speaker of the house has put together a
document and it goes step by step for
the actions the Administration has taken
since January 20th of 2021 President
Biden terminated the national emergency
at the Southwest border President Biden
issued an executive order further
entrenching DCA program Biden unveiled
the US citizenship act which would
provide amnesty the administration
issued an executive order ending
limitations and restrictions on
immigration without certain countries
associated with terrorism then secretary
myor has delivered remarks effectively
explaining the border is open for
illegal immigration by stating that
dhs's Focus would be on
processing on and on and on myor has
issued a memorandum prohibiting
enforcement of immigration laws in
certain areas including schools
Healthcare and Facilities mayorcas
terminated migrant protection protocols
mayorcas issued a memorandum that states
the fact that an individual that an
individual is removable aliens should
not be the sole basis of an enforcement
action I want to enter this with
unanimous consent into the record Mr
chairman like to seek unanimous con so
ordered so what what sorry what is the
document as I mentioned the document is
from the Speaker of the House a list of
actions if we can pause the time please
because this is
Administrative this is a list of actions
that the Administration has taken step
by step since January 20th of 2021 and
it goes in order chronologically of the
actions that the Administration has
taken that have weakened us including
those that secretary my orcus has taken
but it's created by the gentleman is not
recognized right now okay uh and I it's
his time okay you's trying to enter it
that's why I'm asking I'm he's I object
to the entry of this document that was
okay all right that's that's we'll uh
vote on it I suppose then okay are you
asking for a
vote unanimous consent was just
disagreed to are we going to vote on
this yes okay all right we need to clear
the witnesses get the clerks in here and
we'll vote on it stop the clock
also that's not M Tam M Tam okay okay
it's just okay my apologies it's just
Obed to and there is there is no vote so
my my misunderstanding Thank you I'm
assuming that's what you were CL thank
you ranking member the gentleman is
recognized okay and I think and we I'll
make up the time two two minutes and 15
seconds or two minutes and 20 seconds
when you're recognized thank you um
earlier this year director Ray sat here
with secretary my orcus and told us told
this committee that there were still
known and suspected terrorists at large
in the United States that we knew had
matched the terror watch list that came
into this country illegally and that we
didn't know where they were and right
next to him set secretary Mari orcus and
I said what is the policy of DHS when
you know that somebody matches the ter
watch list this is the reason we're
having this hearing because he could not
explain to this committee that DHS
actually has a policy to detain those
people he couldn't explain his
policy that's why we're here because
there are people on the teror watch list
Mr Drummond or attorney general drumond
can you tell us the extent of the
damages that are being done in Oklahoma
as a result of the illegal immigration
to 8 million people who have entered
this country illegally we shut down an
illegal grow every day in the state of
Oklahoma
where we detain and arrest upwards of
dozens of people they're refilled the
next day with those who cross the border
from either in a Mexican cartel or a
Chinese syndicated crime organization it
is
ceaseless do you
believe that the Department of Homeland
Security under the leadership of
secretary mayorcas is upholding the laws
that we currently have on the books to
stop the to stop illegal immigration
into this country I think that there is
a failure to to enforce the laws on
parole removal requirements
detention and the like I couldn't agree
more uh it was earlier said that we
Republicans are going to the Border in
polo shirts and khaki pants or something
to that effect well at least we're going
to the border and at least we're asking
the questions because when you talk to
the border patrol agents they will tell
you that there are no consequences the
consequences do not exist deportation
doesn't exist The Catch and Release
policies are allowing people to the
flood into my community of St Angelo
Texas Midland and Odessa and the fentel
deaths alone that have been catastrophic
to this country over a 100,000 people
should be the sole reason that this
committee comes together I I
hope that my colleagues on the other
side of the aisle when given your time
will examine the facts the facts are
that over eight million people have come
into this country illegally the facts
are that the Secretary of Homeland
Security has not secured our country
against terrorism against fentel against
criminal gangs against traffickers
against sex slavery against any of it he
is complicit in fact he is willfully
complicit which is why he needs to be
impeached I yield back gentleman Ys I
now recognize Mr thodar the gentleman
from Michigan for his five minutes of
question thank you chairman green um and
thank you to our Witnesses for being
here
today uh Professor Bowman
uh would you say that
secretary Amica has done anything that
rise to the level of high crime and
misdemeanor no
Congressman now we know uh our
immigration system is broken for decades
there is not much work done to reform
our immigration
system and secretary Marcus should not
bear the blame for the inherent flaws
within the system he has
inherited and my appeal uh to my
Republican colleagues here is that
rather than getting bogged down in an
impeachment process that seems needless
and devoid of constitutional
Authority Les let's fix shift our Focus
working together in fixing our broken
immigration
system our broken immigration
system is causing our
nation a loss
of billions and trillion dollars in
economic
growth I uh when I was was 24 years old
um living in India having gotten
admission into a PhD program
here and
I made many trips to the American
Embassy in Mumbai to get a student
visa and uh the embassy kept denying me
my student visa they denied my student
visa for four times
times and only on the fifth time I got
my Visa approved because the counselor
who was who had denied my Visa for the
four times had gone to America for her
vacation I mean there is no doubt the
system is
broken we are losing businesses keep
telling me that they can't find a
qualified
uh skilled Workforce that they need to
grow the
businesses Australia and uh Canada has
taken advantage of our broken
immigration system to attract
uh highly skilled workers that our
businesses need to grow and stay on top
of
innovation we we know know uh immigrants
are 60% less likely to be incarcerated
than uh their native
counterparts I just want to take this
time to appeal
um across the aisle to let
us spend our
energies and our constitutional
authority to solve the problems this fix
the broken immigration system that we
have not dealt with for
decades and uh let's not blame the
secretary for our broken immigration
system but let's fix it to help our
economy create jobs and make things
better for all thank
you the gentleman Ys I now recognize the
gentleman from New York Mr Garbarino for
his five minutes of questioning
thank you uh Mr chairman thank you to
Witnesses for being here today you know
I've heard a lot of the statements
coming from my colleagues and they're
acting like we're we've come here on a
whim we're not here on a whim this is
you know we haven't come here lightly
this hearing
today there have been problems at the
borders at the border for years and now
uh every state in the nation every state
in the nation is seeing those effects
negatively uh I just look at my own
state of New York and and and the costs
and of dealing with the crisis at the
border and we have been begging the
administration to do something for
years nothing has been done we're not
we're not here on a
whim something has to be done so that's
why we are here where we are if
leadership can't follow the laws of the
land follow the laws of the land it's
not just policy there's laws there are
written there are laws on the books and
they are being ignored right now by the
current Administration and the current
Secretary if they can't follow the laws
that are on the
books we need to find someone who will
so I think I think we have uh taken the
time and necessary steps to arrive here
in a proper manner it's taken a while in
our country is been at DIS service
because of that it's taken so long uh
but we're here today and uh I appreciate
you all being here and um I'm going to
start with Mr attorney general
Drummond you've described Oklahoma's
challenge with the explosion of
unlicensed and illicit drug
Manufacturing in the state following
Senate the secretary Mar is becoming the
leader of Homeland Security can you
describe more about the challenges of
Oklahoma law enforcement that Oklahoma
law enforcement faces in confronting
this illegal activity especially for
Rural police and Sheriff's departments
who have limited resources let me give
you a tangible example representative uh
one recent drug bust at an illegal grow
operation our agents were processing
those who were committed felonies and
detained and those that were simply
being trafficked in labor and sex and
one of those was identified as a
individual on an HSI detainer for
illegal entry he was supposed to be in
Flushing New York he was supposed to
have on an ankle monitor when we
contacted the field representative and
HSI they said you know charge him with a
felony will come pick him up but he in
fact had not committed a felony then we
were instructed to say please direct him
to turn himself into the nearest HSI
field office and so we did that and let
him go that happens day in and day out
across Oklahoma where we don't have the
resources afforded to detain those that
we know are illegally in the state
committing crimes or complicit in the
committing of crimes you would like to
in New York we have laws that actually
direct that they automatically be
released and we see Crime After Crime
After Crime be committed by the same
person and we and in New York big state
like New York you think we'd have uh
have the ability we do have the ability
to keep people in prison and stop crimes
from happening our laws direct us not to
but at least in Oklahoma you would uh
you would like to be able to to to make
sure that these criminals are not
released back out now New York has one
fewer we have't good um another crisis
Mr attorne General uh that has resulted
from the unprecedented chaos at the
Southwest
Southern border is the explosion of
fentanyl poisonings in this country we
have
seen many far too many in New York from
2018 to 2022 Oklahoma experienced a 735
per increase in fental debts according
to the Oklahoma Bureau Bureau of
Narcotics Oklahoma has a unique status
sitting just north of the Texas and
right along major routes routes away
from the Southwest border for both drug
and human smuggling can you talk about
how the fence crisis over the past few
years has impacted your state so we um
with with the legalization of marijuana
in Oklahoma it's not become the drug of
choice choice to cross the border
fentanyl is now the drug of choice and I
take exception with the representative
who said it is just to say no it it is a
crisis in which we find fentanyl laced
in many drugs such that we instruct our
young children to test every pill don't
if you think you're taking a pain pill
it's probably Lac with fentol and we can
trace those back to uh the porest Border
through which the fentol product comes
in concert with the Mexican cartels and
the Chinese syndicated organizations
this is for any of the attorney generals
um have you we get a lot of
unaccompanied Alien Children in in New
York have you witnessed in your state
these children being used for purposes
of sex trafficking or other forms of
exploitation anyone can jump in and grab
I I will jump in quickly with an example
we uh bust Ed a grow in Northwest
Oklahoma City and in which uh there were
two minor young women from China uh that
were being sex trafficked and we've
intercepted Communication in mainland
China where they're effectively posting
jobs to come to Oklahoma uh quote uh as
massage spa quote able to endure
hardships quote good hygiene and yet
these young women are being exploited
and we don't have a remedy to take care
of
them
and quickly I know Missouri now ranks
fourth on the list of the states at the
highest rates of human trafficking uh in
2021 there were 1100 reported cases
detected cases of human trafficking in
the state of Missouri 327 victims
identified Congressman human trafficking
has increased in my state multiple
hundred% since 2019 I think that answers
your
question yield back gentleman yields I
now recognize the gentleman from Rhode
Island Mr magazine thank you chairman I
I've been listening to all of my
Republican colleagues throughout this
hearing and I'm still struggling to
understand what high crime they believe
the secretary has committed I've heard
that he hasn't achieved operational
control defined as not a single person
crossing the border uh illegally no
Administration has met that standard
I've heard them say that he has failed
to detain everyone who is undocumented
who has come across the border no
Administration has uh under the Biden
Administration secretary morcus uh has
removed three million undocumented
people from this country so when I hear
my colleagues say that deportation does
not exist I can think of three million
people who would disagree with that he
has continued construction of a border
wall that many of us question the
effectiveness of and when the secretary
and the president were were asked do you
think the Wall Works they say no we
don't think it works but we're building
it because the law requires us to do it
they're following the law we Face
difficult challenges at the southern
border there is no question instability
and other countries has driven people to
come to the United States and it has
created a chaotic situation but
unfortunately rather than working with
us and the president and the secretary
to address these challenges too many of
mybl Republican colleagues are focused
more on partisan Grand standing and
campaigning including this impeachment
theater so here's the real truth
President Biden and secretary my orcus
have taken steps to try to secure the
borders but House Republicans have tried
to obstruct them every step of the way
because they want a campaign issue more
than they want to fix the problem here
are the facts in
2022 Democrats passed and the president
signed $86 billion for enhanced border
security more Personnel more funding for
ice additional
technology 200 House Republicans voted
against that funding including every
single Republican member of this
committee who was in office at the time
this year in 2023 House Republicans
passed their so-called limit save grow
act which would have cut the Department
of Homeland Security Budget by 22% %
eliminating
2400 CBP officers every Republican
member of the house voted for that bill
a 22% cut the Republican limit save grow
act I guess is to limit border patrol
and grow
chaos this year this past year President
Biden requested $84 million in his
budget to help states and cities with
the costs associated with incoming
migrants House Republicans propose
cutting that funding to zero so to the
state officials who are here who are
coming from states that are having
challenges with the migrant crisis I've
got bad news for you our Republican
colleagues are trying to zero out the
line item in the budget to help states
and cities I'm a former State Treasurer
myself and that is deeply deeply
distressing and of course most recently
in October President Biden requested $4
billion in supplemental funding for
Border enforcement that would add 1,300
border patrol agents A th000 CBP
officers but House Republicans have not
called a vote on this funding and
they'll say well there's other things in
it that we don't like you know there's a
growing Pro Putin Wing in the house
Republican caucus that doesn't like
Ukraine funding they don't want more
Asylum judges even though that's part of
how we solve the problem at the border
fine call a vote on the parts that you
do like the CBP agents border patrol
you've been sitting on it for three
months if you really truly cared about
solving the problem you would call a
vote instead they've been sitting on it
for three months then went on vacation
for a month while secretary my orcus was
meeting with Senate Republicans and
Senate Democrats to try to come up with
a border plan and House Republicans were
Mia and I know what my colleagues are
going to say they're going to say well
we did hr2 we are trying to do something
don't forget what's in hr2 all right hr2
would require nonprofit organizations to
verify the citizenship of the people
they were serving or else they would
risk losing their Federal funding it
would request coffee shops all across
the country small businesses to do
citizen checks citizenship checks of
their employees zero out the funding for
legal assistance for miners so that once
again we'd have five-year-olds going
into court and standing in front of
judges without no lawyers and we tried
to negotiate with them we tried to put
in amendments to make that bill better
but of course they wouldn't work with us
so let's not forget what's really going
on here the secretary is trying to do
his job House Republicans have been
obstructing him every step of the way
and are now trying to impeach him
because this is about politics for many
of them it is not about solving the
problem at the border which is what we
should be doing with that I yeld back
gentleman yields I now recognize the
gentle lady from Georgia Miss green for
her five minutes of questioning thank
you Mr chairman uh I'd like to bring up
that nothing SP impeachment theater
unlike the uh or you know the last
impeachment of our former president of
the United States Donald J Trump that
was quite a political uh sham
impeachment but today we're talking
about a real impeachment that needs to
take place there have been over 20
occasions that secretary Amicus has
claimed that the border is either closed
or secure starting even back in 2021
when he is on record stating the border
is secure the border is closed again the
border is closed the border is secure he
stated to Fox News Peter Ducey the
border is closed then he stated again uh
to Congressman fluger here on this
committee Congressman fluger asked him
said the border is secure we are we are
executing our plan as he stated to
Congressman fluger secretary America
said I have been very clear and
equivocal in that regard Congressman the
border is no less secure than it was
previously he also uh stated to
Congressman Michael guest on our
committee when he was asked by
Congressman guest do you maintain today
in light of the statements made by Chief
Ortez that the border is secure
secretary morcus replied Congressman I
stand by my prior assessment because
indeed I Define it as Max maximizing the
resources we have to deliver the most
effective results his results have been
quite effective here are some of
secretary mayor's effective results
approximately 10 million illegal border
crossers from over 160 countries have
invaded the United States since
President Biden took office and
Secretary of morcus started his job this
is uh a number com combined with over 8
million encounters and over 1.8 million
got aways in September 2023 over
341,000 illegal border crossers invaded
our country surpassing all national
records secretary morcus is bringing the
results in fiscal year 2023 there were
over three million illegals who invaded
the border the highest number of yearly
illegal alien encounters in US history
that far surpasses uh those that were
supposedly deported there have been
approxim approximately 73,000 special
interest aliens arrested at our border
those are the ones that we know of
ladies and gentlemen there's over 1.8
million Goda aways and we have no idea
how many in that 1.8 million or more are
terrorist are from terrorist Nations we
don't know where they are what they're
doing and what their plans are for the
United States of America including the
states that you're working very hard to
protect these are some some impressive
results most impressive for American
taxpayers is the total federal
expenditures and this is this is just in
2023 stands at 66 Bill 449
m136 th000 but let's talk about total
state and local expenditures stands at
115 billion 68
m730 th000 the total National
expenditures for Border crossers for
2023 stands at
182,780
th000 that is an unbelievable expense
for the American people and the American
taxpayers and what are the results from
secretary mayor's job performance he's
violated the secure Defense Act of 2006
by not maintaining operational control
of our border he's violated the
immigration and nationality act he has
violated the inii by implementing Catch
and Release policies when federal law
specifically mandates the detention and
removable of inadmissible aliens he's
violated the inii he's violated the
guarantee Clause set forth in article 4
section four of the Constitution which
requires the federal government to
protect States against
Invasion and I'd like to just finish
with asking each one of you um in your
position and your experience and the
problems that each of you were dealing
with do you believe that secretary
mayorcas actions and refusal to enforce
the laws warrant
impeachment absolutely
congresswoman he is failed to perform
and is coply inefficient yes the
secretary is acting in violation of the
law and constitutional order thank you
very much I yield back my time Mr
chairman the gentem lady yields I now
recognize M Ramirez uh from Illinois for
her five minutes of questioning thank
you
chairman after a year in this room after
more than 15 hearings and approximately
45 hours of talking and talking and
talking about the Border we come back to
committee not to address 30 years of
failed border policy and political
inaction that's created a humanitarian
crisis in our borders but to pursue a
baseless impeachment today marks a 16th
wasted hearing on the border Mr Bowman
give me a yes or no based on your
knowledge and expertise on impeachments
do you agree that historically
impeachments have been an important tool
to ensure accountability in our
Democratic
institutions yes or no yes thank you and
Mr Bulman if you could be concise with
just one sentence are you aware of any
federal offense secretary mayoras has
committed that could amount to an
impeachable
offense no thank you and for the record
because I think you've had to answer
this a couple times yes or no in your
expert opinion is there a legitimate
basis for this
impeachment no and in your opinion in
today's hearing is this an effect Ive
use of committee resources yes or
no I don't know that's a question I'm an
expert in answering I think that's a
question for the committee let me answer
that I believe it is not the right use
of our time here because I think that we
should be here identifying ways to
address Solutions so this impeachment
proceedings demonstrate that some of my
Republican colleagues do not take this
institution or the responsibilities of
our office seriously there willing to
take impeachment an important tool for
accountability and make a mockery of it
for political gain this is how I know
that they're not taking the humanitarian
crisis within our borderers seriously
because impeachment will not make our
borders any safer for our communities or
for Asylum Seekers and it will not
address the conditions across Latin
America that motivate families to
migrate across jungles and deserts to
our Southern B border so if they were
serious is they would be taking up any
of the topics on this list of
16 16 possible policy Solutions and 16
legislative actions that require US
Congress people to advance including
today we've wasted 16 hearing on
political theater that could have been
better served considering policies on 16
actions right here behind me let me read
them for the record we could be
expanding work permits we could be
increasing border Personnel to expand
assistance to new arrivals we could be
modernizing legal Pathways to
citizenship we could be granting
immigration perau instead of fighting it
we could be addressing and preparing for
climate migration we could be investing
in economic development of Latin
American communities we can end the
Monroe Doctrine we can allocate
resettlement funding for displaced
populations we can lift and reform
time-based immigration bars we can
modernize definitions standards in our
Antiquated system we can establish
humanitarian standards we can improve
upon adjudicatory processing capacity we
can impri Personnel to reduce USCIS
backlogs we can Implement Federal
coordination of resettlement to Interior
cities let me take a breath now let me
go to the 15th we can strengthen
democracy and combat corruption Latin
America we can pass
hr6 the American dream and promise act
and because fento is in fact an issue in
this country let me add a 17th one since
if we wanted to work we can actually get
things done we could actually fund
technological resources to prevent fento
from being smuggled through our ports of
Entry by us Americans so let me say to
you as a proud daughter of immigrants
the wife of a dreamer and the
representative of Illinois 3 I'm here to
get things done we have to get serious
about addressing every policy
opportunity listed behind me today we
could start by Expediting work permits
because let's just be
honest to me Congress this institution
this chamber represents a sacred
responsibility to come together to
realize the solutions and problems
impacting our
constituents and let me tell you that
persecution of immigrants and secretary
mayorcas is not going to change the
price of milk in your District it's not
going to address a shrinking tax base in
your district and it's not going to fill
the vacant positions of Industries in
your local businesses action will action
will address the historic labor shortage
it will increase our Revenue through
taxes it will reduce Supply and
distribution chain challenges and it
will grow our GDP by 1.7 trillion over
the next decade so if we are serious to
have to address this border issue then
let's actually get to do the work that
addresses border policy because policy
in action speaks louder than the 16
hearings and the 48 Hours of talk and
talk and sound bites and photo ops at
the border I have been to the Border my
mother crossed it I was there with her I
am serious about the work we can do here
are you thank you chairman and with that
I yield back the gentle lady yields I
now recognize the vice chair of the
committee uh the gentleman from
Mississippi Mr guest for five minutes
question thank you Mr chairman and uh
before I begin my question I have
something I'd like to submit for the
record uh Mr chairman I'd like to submit
for the record a post uh from January 15
2019 titled the case for imp M of Donald
Trump part three written by Mr Bowman
one of our Witnesses today in which he
takes a very highly a view of
impeachment uh in which he says that
then president Donald Trump could be
impeached over foreign policy
differences uh and I quote from that
article it said surely we can impeach a
president for needless shattering a
basket of good treaties and entire
intricate web of foreign relations they
support consider Mr Trump's rolling
destruction of America's foreign policy
and goes on to say there is powerful
evidence that the framers uh included
conducts and damaging to the US policy a
category of impeachable behavior I think
that that contradicts the testimony that
we've heard here today uh Mr chairman
from Mr Bowman uh and so I would like to
submit uh this article uh for the record
without objection so
ordered uh thank you Mr chairman to our
Witnesses thank you for being here uh
today uh
we see the numbers on the Southwest
border continue to grow exponentially
each and every day uh as our attorney
generals know you are more aware of
these numbers uh than we are because you
deal with the after effects those
300,000 that came across the border just
last month many of those will end up in
your communities your testimonies as
I've read them says that your
communities your States your cities that
you'll be responsible for housing for
feeding for educating for health care
you talk about the strain that this is
going to be placing on the criminal
justice system and then you also talk
about the total lack of response from
our federal government and so first I
want to apologize to you uh that you are
not getting the help that you need from
the federal government and the help that
you need is not us sending you money
after these immigrants have come into
your community the help that you need is
us stopping the Immigrant from coming
across the border what we saw is we need
policies similar to what we saw under
the previous administration where we
were able to stop immigrants from coming
across the border the last two witnesses
on the other side try to place blame on
this on the Republican party that we
need to be doing more and I know that
our attorney generals know and I hope
those watching on television know that
this Republican party has done our part
part we have passed hr2 the most
comprehensive immigration package that
has been made through the the the at
least the House of Representatives in
decades would substantially overhaul the
crisis that we see in addition to that
we passed Our House Appropriations Bill
dealing with Homeland Security in that
House Appropriations Bill we added
additional border patrol agents we added
Merit pay bonuses for those agents who
had been there for a while we put money
in the budget for technology and we even
said hey we got to get back to building
the wall something that I think many of
us will agree is a has to be part of
that comprehensive package and so for my
friends across the aisle who want to
place a brain on Republicans that we
haven't done anything look at our bills
that are sitting over there on Chuck
Schumer's desk that he's not taken up in
the Senate as they continue to sit sit
there as they continue to fiddle Rome
Burns and you were having to deal with
the aftermath of that and so I have a
question for you and Marjorie Taylor
green talked a little bit about this
we've repeatedly had the secretary here
he's come here time and time and time
again and every time that he's been
asked a question by me and my colleagues
he has repeatedly said that our
Southwest border is
secure regardless of the facts and
figures and anything statistically you
show him where that is not the case that
is what he continues to hang his hat on
that this border is secure and that
there is no crisis well we know there's
a crisis because you see it and so my
question here in the last uh just 30
seconds that I have and I'm going to ask
all of all four of our Witnesses a very
simple yes or no question do you believe
that there is a crisis at the southern
border and is the border secure so I
guess I'm going to ask each of you two
two questions is the border secure we'll
start there and the second one is do you
believe that there's a crisis attorney
general kuton we'll begin with you
Congressman the southern border is
absolutely not secure and this is far
beyond a crisis at this
point similarly it is not secure and we
have a crisis General Brahman General
Bailey the border is not secure in the
crisis of historically epic proportion
and Mr
Bowman as I said at the out said I'm not
an an expert on immigration policy I
don't have any any opinion on this
question what's your personal
opinion my personal opinion is that
there is uh as there has been for
decades and indeed probably a century
and a half in this country a lot of
controversy about immigration policy
there's been there's controversy about
the way in which immigration policy is
being administered to the southern
border I think at the moment we seem to
have more problems in that area than
we've had in some past eras yes
thank you for your very politically
correct answer so with that I yield back
thank you the chair now recognizes as Mr
Ivy of Maryland for his five minutes of
questions thank you Mr chairman uh I
want to thank all of you all for coming
today just briefly I wanted to respond
to the comment about um legislation
sitting on Senator Schumer's desk you
know with respect to
hr2 um I I think it was clear before it
was passed frankly as we came through
the committee here Democrats offered
amendments all which were rejected
Republicans put in poison pill language
especially with respect to not only
abortion on some of these bills but
cutting off Federal funding to uh
agencies and you know social social
support groups like Red Cross Chris
Catholic church and the like so the fact
that you send it over there knowing it
was DOA I think is not
um much to uh praise uh for the effort
but more
importantly all of speaker Johnson s all
of us home three weeks early um the
Senate stayed and the Democrats and
Republicans were actually working on
bipartisan legislation to try and
address the Border crisis working with
the White House and yes secretary
mayorcas to try and find an agreement
meanwhile the House Republicans instead
of working with that group and joining
in those negotiations did a road trip to
Texas for a photo op opportunity to talk
about the issues at the border so if we
want to get serious about it oh by the
way President Biden sent uh supplemental
legislation man I think it was in
September with for additional funding no
response from the Republican colleagu so
if you can um so you know part of that
what's one of the minor things addressed
in this article behind me worst Congress
ever that goes to the ineffectiveness of
this Congress under the house Republican
leadership to get anything done that's
critical we've probably gone through the
issues of pending legislation Israel
Ukraine fisa all the things that haven't
got done that need to get done the
border is another one I hope my
Republican colleagues will get busy on
that uh with respect to the the actual
uh issue of impeachment from a legal
standpoint I went through the testimony
that the uh generals provided I only saw
two paragraphs in all three of your
testimony with respect to that and none
of it actually spoke to the language in
the
Constitution um with respect to treason
bribery High crimes and misdemeanors uh
and and I thought that was interesting I
I I you know Professor Turley um who is
not necessarily my favorite but
Republican seem to like him he testifies
a lot in fact at the opening hearing for
the impeachment hearings against Joseph
Biden uh the oversight committee uh
leadership called three experts to
testify Turley was one of the three and
one of the things Turley said like he's
saying here is that there's no basis for
impeachment he taken this position with
respect to secretary mayor workus um and
you know the fact that none of the
witnesses that have been called today by
the Republicans actually have that kind
of experience with respect to
impeachment and expertise and I thought
was interesting I I'll I'll add this too
you can put it down um we want to add to
the record a couple of documents one is
um the turly letter which I'll offer in
a moment but the second is a letter uh
an oped that was written by Jos josua
matz and uh Norm Eisen who are members
of former members of the House Judiciary
Committee who've actually worked on
impeachment hearings before and they
talked about the absence of evidence to
support impeachment here and a couple of
of respects that I think are important
that we go through one is the issue of
maladministration so the framers when
they put the the provision and they went
through different iterations of it but
they ended up with the language they've
got but excluded a term like Malad
Administration so that we wouldn't have
impeachment hearings for policy
differences because and this is James
Madison if we did that the Senate could
be picking and choosing and throwing out
people just on policy disagreements
we're really that we should leave that
to the president president gets to make
a selection pick his cabinet or her
cabinet hopefully one day and make the
decisions on who should be ruling there
uh the issue here and that's pointed out
in the Eisen letter uh and with respect
to the group of uh professors led by
Lawrence tribe and others who point this
out this is just a maladministration
dispute my colleagues over here are
talking about the borders run a muck and
all of that and I you know I hear that
point but that's just a policy
difference I haven't the in the
testimony that was given points about
bribery treason crime High crimes and
misdemeanors don't seem to have been
made there's no legal violation there's
no criminal act there's no basis that
the framers were looking for to remove a
a a Cabinet member from Office that's a
very serious step and by the way I got a
print out of all of the
impeachment legislation that my
colleagues have put together I I think
Miss Taylor green alone just has eight
impeachment resolutions in this Congress
eight uh three I think against secretary
mayorcas so if we're going to be serious
about this let's let's try and get to
the issues with respect to the actual
legal piece and I apologize Mr chairman
but I I'll conclude there and I look
forward to actually having a debate and
experts who can speak to this uh from
expertise or scholarship on the issue of
the standard for impeachment the
gentleman yields uh the chair recognizes
the gentleman from New York Mr Loda for
his five minutes and questions more than
any other cabinet secretary to America's
history secretary mayorcas is failing
America but don't take my word for it 68
% of Americans disapprove of the Biden
administration's handling of the
Southern border
68% 75% of Americans see the Border
situation as either a crisis or a
serious problem
75% so while our country is divided on
so many policy issues there is
overwhelming support from across America
for secretary me orcus to finally secure
our Southern border 68% and 75% yet the
Administration and my colleagues from
the other side of the aisle won't change
their border policies secretary morcus
won't change his policies or approach
the administration won't reinstate
remain in Mexico and blue cities won't
repeal their Sanctuary City policies um
secretary morcus won't change his border
policies all while tens of thousands of
Americans are dying from the fentol
being smuggled across his open border
secretary morcus won't and can't
properly vet the tens of thousands of
migrants he is paroling into our country
from nations with whom America is
adversarial so here we are so what do we
in this Congress do when somewhere
around 75% of our constituents and by
the way from Blue districts and red
districts and purple districts want
accountability 75% what do we do when
tens of thousands of Americans are dying
what do we do when potentially hundreds
of terrorist sleeper cells are being
hatched every day inside of America's
borders what do we do do we do nothing
do we wrap ourselves in some sort of
biocracy and find some sort of legal
reasoning not to do anything or do we
act and let me State quite clearly that
I do not take impeachment lightly
impeachment is meant for the most
serious grave circumstances when there
is a true failure and will dereliction
of Duty has occurred and in this case
secretary me orcus has committed three
specific violations which warrant
impeachment he has neglected his duty to
secure our border he has abused his
power to exercise proper discretion over
America's immigration process and
secretary morcus has breached America's
public trust and no matter what the
secretary or the president say the
numbers speak for themselves since
President Biden has been on office there
have been 4.5 million migrant encounters
at the Southwest border in addition to
over 1.2 million goway who evaded US
border patrol agents in the last two
years those numbers are larger than the
population of Los Angeles the second
largest city in the United States and
let me be abundantly clear this is not
the failure of the hardworking men and
women who are out there every day in the
front line of this crisis this is a
failure of leadership at the highest
levels right up to secretary mayoras and
President Biden and while there are at
least three criteria which Merit
secretary mayor is impeachment and
removal today I would like to focus on
just one of them secretary me orcus
neglecting his duty to secure the Border
ten attorney general kutson good to be
with you here today sir and thanks for
your hard work keeping your residence in
Montana safe uh in October sir you
joined a coalition of 27 State Attorneys
General in a petition urging secretary
mayorcas to end his uh policy of mass
Catch and Release and I was hoping that
you could Define sir for Americans who
may be watching from home today uh and
maybe not so familiar with this topic uh
what Catch and Release means sir thank
you Congressman I can so generally
speaking uh congressmen under under 8
USC 1225 uh the law is very clear the
the secretary has a duty to detain every
single alien that enters the country
period hard stop shall be detained uh
there is one exception there's a caseby
casee exception listed under Section
1182 which allows on a case-by casee
individual temporary basis for either
humanitarian or for for public Justice
reasons uh an exception under secretary
mayor's Direction uh that basically has
been turned into not a case-by casee
analysis but rather a mass catch and
release uh where those individuals are
no longer given an individual
investigation an individual notice to
appear in front of a judge uh they were
given a notice to report court that
appears nowhere in the Federal Register
that appears nowhere in federal law and
was basically used as a mass catch and
release program so that's what we're
talking so would you agree that the mass
Catch and Release that is not done on a
case-by casee basis is inconsistent with
the laws passed by Congress and signed
into law by both uh by presidents of
both parties absolutely Congressman
there is no legal Authority anywhere in
federal code for Mass release of
immigrants into this country thank you
I'm out of time my yield
back the gentleman yields the chair now
recognizes the gentleman from new New
Jersey Mr Menendez for his five minutes
thank you Mr chairman I'm frustrated
that Republicans on this committee have
chosen to engage in this political
exercise and are proceeding to willfully
misinterpret the US Constitution and
every precedent from the past 250 years
by impeaching secretary my orcus last
week one of our Republican colleagues
said he was not likely to support any
compromised border bill because quote
I'm not willing to do too damn much
right now to help a Democrat and to help
Joe Biden's approval rating I will not
help the Democrats try to improve this
man's dismal approval ratings I'm not
going to do it why would I end quote why
would he because we need to work
together to address the critical issues
that our committee has jurisdiction over
because we owe it to our constituents
and our communities to meet this moment
but that's not what this hearing is
about because when you talk about
approval ratings and not wanting to help
Democrats not wanting to help this
Administration not wanting to to help
our president you undermine the
seriousness of what is being discussed
today and you make clear what this has
always been political Pursuit speaking
of politics I have a few yes or no
questions for the three attorney
generals here today you are all elected
officials is that correct
yes I was appointed to my office subject
to election by the people understood and
you are all Republicans is that correct
yes and lastly in 2016 and 2020
president Trump won in the states that
you serve as Attorney General of yes
yes so it's fair to conclude that it's
politically beneficial for you to be
supportive of the former president and
his policies and oppose President
Biden's policies as is the case for all
of our Republican colleagues here on
this committee but constitutional law is
clear on this point policy political
differences are not appropriate grounds
for impeachment Mr Bowman is that
correct yes or no it is thank you House
Republicans have said they will not
support quote another dime end quote for
DHS until the enactment of hr2 their
extreme anti-immigrant border bill that
would severely restrict our legal
immigration system a bill that would
endanger migrant lives by denying Asylum
Seekers their legal right to seek
protection in the United States and
reinstating dangerous policies that
Force migrants to remain in unsafe
conditions such as remain in Mexico but
Republicans know that hr2 is so cruel
and unworkable that will never become
law but that's what they use to say
we're doing something here that's what
we're doing on this committee and this
Congress instead said Republicans could
support President Biden's request for
funding for more CBP officers and
Fentanyl detection technology to
increase cbp's capacity to identify Bad
actors and drugs at our Southern border
but no they won't support this funding
or any solution that would help this
Administration carry out border security
efforts because it would weaken their
political talking points that's been
their strategy this entire
Administration in this committee we have
real opportunities to work on
substantive issues together across the
St said my Republican colleagues are
distorting this committee and its
mandate to safeguard our nation's
Homeland Security into a vehicle for
false narratives about migrants and the
Border Professor Bowman let me ask you a
question is it appropriate to impeach
Secretary of my orcus because of policy
dis
disagreements no is it appropriate to
impeach secretary mayorcas because
Republicans refuse to properly fund DHS
and allow him to do his
job well I don't want to characterize um
the actions of the Republicans but
certainly don't you don't impeach we'll
take your first part of the answer
politics Professor Bowman is it
appropriate to impeach secretary ofor is
because Republicans would rather narrate
a crisis to score political points than
work with the ad Administration to
strengthen the security of our border
certainly not impeach it's certainly not
appropriate to impeach a cabinet officer
over political or policy disagreements I
agree uh attorney general Drummond um
thank you for your testimony your R
testimony I went through it I appreciate
it this day and age we deal a lot with
sourcing and uh citations I noticed
there was a single Source in yours and
it was to the Federation for American
Immigration Reform uh are you aware that
the Southern Poverty Law Center has
designated the Federation for American
Immigration Reform as a hate group whose
leaders have ties to white nationalist I
am not yeah um completely understandable
I will just let you know that a lot of
the sources that have been used and all
this investigative materials and reports
have been fourth by the majority have
relied on far-right anti-immigrant um
think tanks and groups that are not
aligned with what I believe our
country's morals and values are and
that's a problem with a lot of the
reports that this hearing that this
impeachment process and procedure has
been based on um and that's where this
all falls apart for me uh I really wish
we were engaging in a thoughtful uh
exercise I really wish we were trying to
solve some of the challenges that we're
facing but that's not what today is
about and with that I yield back
gentleman Ys
uh
ranking
yes Mr Goldman referenced two articles
uh turle uh and Isen and the clerk has
already collected them but it was just a
unanimous consent to incl in record
actually Mr iy yeah I think I was
watching back there I saw it was Mr iy
so yeah so ordered and
thank you Mr chairman and thank you all
for being here today and providing this
important testimony um uh let let's be
clear about this the Biden
Administration and secretary Mar orcus
uh did not inherit uh the crisis at the
border they created
it ignoring the desperate pleas from
affected and scared families Nationwide
secretary mayorcas has intentionally
disregarded the law leaving the Border
open to an end less stream of Migrant
drug and cartel
members my time as a sheriff and if I
was neglecting my duties to enforce the
law it would have cost me my job
secretary should be held to the same
standard uh Mr Drummond uh your story
about the illegal Chinese National who
executed a three men that's really stuck
with me uh the reports are clear that
terrorist organizations are exploiting
the vulnerability of our nation's border
it is simply irresponsible that
secretary May orcus continues to ignore
the significant threat to our national
security do you believe secretary M
orcus actions have embolden terrorists
around the world and is it fair to say
he has intentionally ignoring our
nation's current laws that should make
it harder to enter our country illegally
I think that it is indisputable that we
have uh terrorist terrorist
organizations invading my state we've
identified numerous gangs numerous
syndicated crime organizations and they
only grow on a daily
basis Mr gudon and Mr B would you care
to comment on this as
well I would point out that uh the two
lawsuits that we have pinning right now
dealing with the parole process the
abuse of the parole process secretary
May's violation of the plain text of the
statute as it relates to parole and his
promulgation of the circumvention rule
have been described as engaging in a
child trafficking delivery service so
it's not just that he's emboldening the
enemies of the United States he's
actually actively participating in some
of the harms by using uh support
networks to allow for illegal
immigration that used to be considered
unlawful through the stroke of his pin
without Congressional
Authority Congressman I wholeheartedly
agree I mean I can tell you the The
increased um gang activity in my state I
can tell you the increase in firearm
crime in my state increase in officer
involved shootings uh we can tie this
all directly to the the cartel drug
problems that is flooding my State uh
We've we've seen fentanyl seizures in my
state Rise by some measurements up from
11,000 per in my state just since 2019
uh those are numbers that we were not
seeing prior to this Administration
change I I think that's pretty
staggering thank you Mr drumman and your
state and many others we've had taken
steps to safeguard our communities
because we we cannot rely this
Administration to protect us for example
Mississippi my home state has set up a
fental strike force uh to tackle the
influx of drugs I notice that the state
of Oklahoma has also formed a similar
task force uh can you elaborate on some
of the findings of that task force yes
then we have created an organized crime
task force with the explicit purpose of
coordinating with other state agencies
to tackle this uh endemic of illegal
immigration in the state of Oklahoma and
the drugs and the and the detriment that
they drag into the state and uh it's
come at an extremely high cost for the
state we've allocated an additional $3
million from my office just to staff
that and the toll on human uh it it's
just remarkable are there any
recommendations the task force findings
uh that you could recommend to the
Congress to consider uh implementing on
a federal level it would be very helpful
if uh the terrorism category if cartels
would be listed as foreign terrorist
organizations right now they they fall
outside that immigration
admissibility uh def definition and if
they were designated as such it would
give us strength in deportation also in
your testimony you pointed out that
smaller law enforcement departments are
outmanned outgunned and ill equipped to
address the threats coming across our
border particularly the threats from the
Mexican and Chinese drug syndicates uh I
can sympathize uh with this and
certainly understand the stress that is
placed on our rural Law Enforcement
Officers when dealing with such a rise
in crime as departments are forced and
stret their resources uh addressing
pressing issues uh can you talk a little
bit about the Ripple effects and the
gaps it leaves in our critical areas of
law enforcement uh and safety for our
communities it it has truly taken the
attention of all law enforcement in the
state of Oklahoma toward this issue
where we have uh you know a shell owner
buying a prop piece of property pushing
up BMS of dirt with bulldozers Manning
those with uh semi-automatic weapons at
the top very intimidating for our local
law enforcement they're outgunned
outmanned and our limit our our
resources are stretched in the state
thank you Mr Drummond and the other
witnesses as well for your input today
once again the committee has shown that
secretary May orcus Bears direct
responsibility for the chaos at the
border I will not tolerate the
overlooking of real threats that are
jeopardizing innocent lives his failures
demand Swift accountability Mr chairman
I yield back gentlemen yields I now
recognize a gentle lady from Nevada uh
Miss Titus for her five minutes a
question thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you to the witnesses you know it
often I see my colleagues across the
aisle brandishing the Constitution like
a sword you love to quote it you love to
cite it you love to talk about what the
founding fathers intended that original
intent but it's kind of like Shakespeare
and the Bible those who talk about the
most have seldom read it and really may
not understand what's in there you know
if you talk about original intent uh you
you're saying what the founding fathers
intended now it's a smaller country
smaller population smaller budget we had
no AI we had no drones how do we know
what they intended well often we don't
but in this case we know exactly what
they intended all you have to do is look
at some of the notes from the convention
of the Constitution by Madison who did
not want to include the uh Mal
administration because it was too broad
and policy oriented look at Federalist
Paper 65 by Hamilton conservative at the
time who did not want to uh include this
broader interpretation of impeachment
now you've also heard Mr Bowman's
arguments of respect scholar who you
have demeaned his expertise by
insinuating oh he's just a democratic uh
witness uh but he is not alone in this
position Mr turley's letter was
mentioned uh there is an article in the
hill about another letter from legal
Scholars this is a group of legal
Scholars who wrote a letter to our
chairman and the leadership of the house
uh speaker Johnson that says their
proposed Grant stands for impeaching
mayorcas are the stuff of ordinary
policy disagreement in the field of
immigration enforcement they go on to
say that uh this is inappropriate they
admit they have varying views on the
wisdom and success of mayor's work on
the immigration policy but they say you
cannot have impeachment based on this
policy it is a I quote Stark departure
from the Constitution now these legal
Scholars included in this letter are
Donald a who served as us Deputy
attorney general under George HW Bush
Stuart gearon who served as acting us
attorney general during Clinton and also
served in the Justice Department under
Bush you have Mr Turley also included in
this there's even a quote by derkowitz
who says that this is in appropriate use
of impeachment so Mr Bowman in with his
expertise does not stand a alone in
condemning this use of impeachment for
political reasons now I look at this
resolution that we're supposed to be
considering that was offered by Miss
Taylor green and aside from the fact
that it's got some punctuation and
grammatical errors it lists some ways
that the uh the secretary has been
effective in the amount of fentanyl that
has been seized at the border the number
of people who were caught on the
terrorist watch list before they came
into the country those are all evidence
that he is carrying out his duty what I
don't see anywhere in this resolution
nor have I heard from any of my
colleagues nor any of our Attorneys
General is how impeaching the secretary
is going to solve all these problems
how's it going to get rid of these
illegal Grove places in Oklahoma how's
it going to get rid of all the
terrorists who are coming into Missouri
how is it going to solve the the fenol
problem uh in in these other whatever
other state oh Montana uh because we've
gotten rid of Mr maoris if anybody can
add that and tell us how getting rid of
him is going to make a difference I'd
like to hear it we hear over in the
Senate Mr lford Senator Langford who is
a republican saying well you can just
switch one secretary for another it's
not going to make any difference so
perhaps we could talk about how getting
rid of Mr moror is through this
uh impeachment process is going to make
a
difference I hear nothing did you want
does a general lady Y no I'm not going
to okay all right so since I gave you
I'd gladly i' gladly answer the question
I gave you an opportunity I gave you
okay I'll y I'll okay all right well in
in my previous testimony I've shared
that the policies that he's implemented
has allowed the car mer Garland agreed
with this that that they're flooding The
Crossing site
tying up the border patrol causing them
to concentrate and then the the the
fenel and the other things are coming
across the border outside now I get the
argument that's often made about what's
captured is mostly captured at you're
not I take my time back chairman you're
not answering my question how getting
rid of mayorcas is going to solve these
problems what you really want to do is
get rid of President Biden you want to
get rid of President Biden and then
perhaps you can put your own secretary
in there that will come up with
different policy but just impeaching
mayorcas we we'll have another
appointment of another secretary who
follows the policy of the administration
and you won't like that either so thank
you Mr Bowman for your expertise and I
you back the gentle lady yields I now
recognize a gentleman from New York Mr
Diaz bazito for his five minutes
question thank you Mr chairman and it's
clear that uh the disapproval of the
policies of Joe Biden and secretary
mayorcas are not just specific uh to
Republicans or conservatives the numbers
that were shared by my good friend from
newor New York Mr Loda 75% of people
have said that the border is the biggest
issue facing this country you talk about
numbers fiscal year 21 since fiscal year
8,542 th000 people have come across our
borders over 3 million in fiscal year 23
in November 308,000 and change 242,000
at our Southern border
312 Terror terrorists who have come
across Ross on our Terror watch list in
fiscal year 21 1.8 million Goda aways
that we know about and many more that we
don't it's cost cities and states
throughout this country
$451 billion dollar with a B there's
been over 70,000 Americans killed by
fentol that have come across but from
cartels we've been asked the question is
this about policy or is this about the
things that
mayorcas has committed well if you ask
me all those numbers is a complete
betrayal to this
country we
talk and has been mentioned by
colleagues that again this is political
theater this is Republicans
conservatives using the Border as a
narrative as we go towards an election
this isn't a narrative it's not one
created by the Republicans and I'll I'll
take us back to my home state of New
York where you have Democrats our
governor has said flat out there's no
room left in New York there's no room at
the Inn don't send migrants here anymore
we've heard a Democrat city mayor mayor
Adams who I disagree with virtually
everything about but this I actually
agree with he has said that the migrant
issue in New York City will destroy New
York so this doesn't seem like it's
political theater it doesn't seem like
it's a narrative that's been created by
Republicans and conservatives because
you now have Democrats in these blue
States and and Sanctuary states and
cities who agree with
us just last night we had children told
in New York City that they can no longer
attend school in person they have to do
it virtually because their school is now
being used to house migrants now just
think about that for a second we want to
talk about the failed policies this
isn't just a policy this is intent May
orcus has intent tionately intentionally
betrayed this country people are
claiming that they want to come here for
a better way of life for
democracy for a chance at that American
Dream for a better
education and yet children who came here
correctly children who were born here
last night were told that they cannot go
to school because there's no room for
them because it's being used by migrants
that's the height of hypocrisy and if
you ask me it is a betrayal of this
country Mr gner drumman in the in your
testimony you talked about how smaller
law enforcement agencies feel that they
are ill equipped to handle the threat
stemming from the border crisis can you
talk about how the Border crisis impacts
the resources of smaller police agencies
and what the officers in those
departments are feeling well certainly
it strains the resources and is wildly
intimidating to our local law
enforcement where they have maybe a a
police force of three or four in a
community of 2,000 and yet they have
four or five illegal grows that are
populated by illegal immigrants Mexican
cartel members Chinese syndicated crime
organization members with semi assault
semi-automatic rifles abundant and they
are unwilling to go in and I know the
answer to this but I want to ask it so
it's on the record because I think it's
another clear indicator of May orcus is
failure of his oath and the fact that
he's betrayed this country do you know
or have you experienced law enforcement
agencies to your knowledge that have
said that they have lacked notification
and information and intelligence sharing
from federal Partners when it comes to
uh migrants I I would say the
cooperation with our federal agencies is
high in Oklahoma we have an excellent
rep working relationship so I commend
the federal agencies working with
Oklahoma I think it goes at a higher
level and that's the implementation of
the laws of of the United States right M
Mr nson you want to comment on that only
to I completely agree with my colleague
here the level of cooperation with with
Federal DEA uh with our us attorney's
office in Montana has been very very
high and very excellent uh customs in
Border Patrol that my dad we're a
Northern Tier State we work with them a
lot but certainly the message has come
down from secretary May arcus and from
onh high that uh we're going to just
flagrantly ignore portions of federal
law and and that is really the point
that I was trying to make he has made it
very clear that he wants to ignore
federal law there are uh you're lucky in
your states to have great Communications
but there has been and there have been
testimony In This Very uh Committee of
people who led local law enforcement
agencies who have said I mean take for
example uh the airport and JFK where
they were housing migrants where there
was Zero Communications between law
enforcement agencies uh because they
just didn't want to share the
information uh with that my time's
expired Mr chairman I back gentleman y i
now recognize Mr Goldman the gentleman
from New York for his five minutes
questioning thank you very much Mr
chairman I find it really difficult to
sit here listening to my colleagues on
the other side of the aisle slander
personally a cabinet secretary who has
committed much of his life to this
government and our Public Service he was
a US attorney he's worked multiple
stints in the department of of Homeland
Security and you're certainly welcome to
disagree with how he executes his job
you're welcome to criticize him you're
welcome to make the case to the American
people as to why secretary
mayorcas in executing President Joe
Biden's immigration policy should be
removed from office at The Ballot Box
but to come in here over and over and
over
again and to personally attack and
slander without any
evidence a cabinet secretary who has
committed so much of his life to this
country who
himself comes from a Cuban family
escaping difficult circumstances in his
country who is an immigrant and
immigrant family
himself you should be ashamed of
yourself it's enough you want to talk
policy let's talk policy I agree we have
problems at the border let's talk about
how we can solve them but instead of
actually going over to the Senate this
committee which has the committee of
jurisdiction over border policy that is
being negotiated right now by a
bipartisan group in the Senate with
secretary mayorcas instead of actually
engaging in those substantive
negotiations to reach some sort of a
bipartisan agreement to address the
problems we are sitting here with a
charade of a sham impeachment hearing
with expert impeachment Witnesses who
are Republican officials uh political
officials suing the Department of
Homeland
Security another hearing it's the same
hearing we've had 10 12
times same Pig different lipstick
because we're now going to call it an
impeachment
hearing so who do we have
here and I am sure all three of you are
excellent Attorneys
General um but I have never heard your
names mentioned in the category of Mr
Bowman who is a legal expert on
impeachment and as far as I can tell
none of your States actually are are on
the
border so I don't understand why we are
sitting here in a quote impeachment
hearing with three Attorneys General
from different states who are Republican
officials and have absolutely no
expertise on
impeachment the reason is because the
last time the Republicans did that and
they brought in their so-called experts
on impeachment for the first and only
oversight public
hearing they were embarrassed because
their own experts acknowledg that there
is insufficient evidence to impeach
President Biden so who do we have
here we have Attorneys General who are
are suing secretary mayorcas and the
government to stop him from
implementing his policy to address the
issues at the border that's
right so one one rule that uh the
department has implemented was the
Asylum processing rule which would allow
Asylum officers rather than immigration
courts to decide Asylum applications for
those placed in expedited removal to
significant ly expedite the process that
might reduce the backlog that might
create a disincentive to come that's
something that secretary mayoras did to
address the Border no you sued him to
stop him from doing
that how about the circumvention rule
well that is the circumvention excuse me
how about the uh the Asylum
circumvention rule which says that you
have to either appear at a Port of Entry
or have first sought Asylum from a
neighboring country that would reduce
the the people who could apply for
Asylum no you sued them you sued them to
stop them from doing that and how about
trying to
address the uh parole
decisions to allow some people to come
in and be able to actually have work
authorizations so that they are not just
sitting on the doll no you sued them so
this is what we have we have
Republicans suing secretary my orcus to
stop him from implementing his policy to
address the issues of the border and now
we're going to impeach him because you
say he's not addressing the issues at
the border which do you
want I yield
back the gentleman yels I now recognize
Miss Lee for uh the gentle lady from
Florida for five minutes of testimony
thank you Mr chairman much has been said
today by our colleagues across the aisle
about this hearing and the purposes for
it it's been called a waste of time it's
been called a charade it's been
suggested that it's repetitive or
unnecessary to suggest that this hearing
is any of those things or to suggest
that this hearing is tantamount than
nothing more than a discussion of policy
differences is to fundamentally deny the
seriousness the scope the scale of the
catastrophe at our Southern border and
the testimony of these Witnesses who are
here today and every witness that has
come before them to testify in front of
this committee about the seriousness of
this crisis we are here today because
secretary Alejandro mayorcas has
intentionally gone around and subverted
the immigration laws of the United
States of America we are here today
because secretary Alejandro moras has
repeatedly defied orders from courts
directing him to cease and desist
certain policies which he continues to
utilize we are here today because the
Department of Homeland Security has
defied inquiries from Congress trying to
get to the bottom of the scope and the
scale of this crisis and we are here
today because secretary mayorcas has
defied Congressional directives related
to spending Congressional directives as
to how money was supposed to be
spent we are here because there is an
unchecked flood of illegal immigration
in our Southern border that is
destroying not just border communities
but communities around our country today
alone we have heard extraordinary and
compelling testimony about the utter
lawlessness that is occurring in this
Administration attorney general kudon
shared with us that he perceives a
refusal to Faithfully execute the laws
of the United States and shared stories
from his State about human trafficking
and Fentanyl trafficking and the
devastation that has occurred because of
our wideopen Southern border attorney
General Drummond commented on the
failure to enforce our laws and how that
has affected his State he also shared
the extraordinary cost that it incurs at
his State because we are not enforcing
our laws in our border and attorney
general Bailey touched on the issue of
parole which has become an absolute
farce and workaround for following our
laws he's said perverting the plain text
of the law and indeed that's exactly
what is happening in my state Florida we
too have been forced to sue the
Department of Homeland Security to
attempt to achieve any semblance of
lawful behavior and
policy United States District Court
Judge Kent
wetheral in an order directing that
secretary mayorcas vacate the parole
program said
quote secretary morcus has turned the
southern border into a meaningless Line
in the Sand and little more than a speed
bump for aliens flooding into the
country with that
backdrop attorney general Bailey I'd
like to turn your attention specifically
to the question of Parole
Authority on July 26 2023 before the
house Judiciary Committee secretary
meorc has testified the Department of
Homeland security has used our Parole
Authority consistent with the law and
consistent with past practices of
different administrations he also
claimed that his department is using the
Parole Authority uh consistent with the
laws still in your opinion is secretary
mayorcas is implementation of the parole
statute lawful and is his implementation
of this policy affecting the security of
the United States his policy
implementation is unlawful in violation
of the plain text of the statute
thereby forcing a lawsuit from several
like-minded State Attorneys General
because of the DraStic terrible harm
that's occurring on the streets in our
communities attorney general Drummond
you shared some of the devastating
effects that failure to secure our
border is having on your state in your
opinion are these policies affecting the
security and safety of your state and of
our country the laws of the immigration
nationality act are clear and
unequivocal and they are not being uph
help and attorney general kudon would
you share your perspective on the harm
to your state and our country that is
being posed by failure uh to follow our
laws 1 1700% increase in fentanyl deaths
confirmed State Crime Lab fentel deaths
since 2019 congresswoman 11,000 per
increase in fentel seizures multiple
100% increase in human trafficking
investigations since 2019 those numbers
M speak for
themselves thank you Mr chairman I yield
back gent lady yields I now
recognize Mr
gon you're up are you ready or you want
to go ahead with somebody else okay
recognize Mr Garcia for his five minutes
of
testimony thank you Mr chairman um just
want to just reiterate that I it's been
said this very many times today by our
our uh colleagues here um on the house
side on the Democratic side that we all
know that this impeachment inquiry this
effort to try to impeach the secretary
uh is a complete political stunt in sham
and I just want to reiterate that we all
know it's a political employ that's not
grounded in the facts truth and has been
conjured up for just one simple purpose
and that's to score cheap political
points against the Biden
Administration we also know that we've
had articles from The New York Times and
other
Publications just really laying out that
this is all about uh this pursuit of
impeaching mayorcas uh it's about this
kind of effort that's been started quite
frankly by even a member of this
committee uh for many many many months
um that's all just really about hurting
the president now Professor Bowman
Republican leaders have been quoted
promising donors that they would impeach
secretary mayorcas and fundraisers back
in April of 2023 do you believe this
committee has uncovered any evidence of
high crimes or misdemeanor since that
time
not that I'm aware of and thank you and
let's let's be clear what we're moving
ahead with today is because extremists
including some folks uh that are in this
committee have demanded it over and over
again now I want to give a couple quotes
from some members of the house uh
Congressman Andy Biggs told Newsmax that
Republicans quote have nothing to
campaign on Andy said that he was
embarrassed by this now Congressman chip
Roy has said and I want to quote I want
my Republican colleague colleages to
give me one thing one that I can go to
campaign on to say that we did just one
end quote and in fact this last Monday
he went on TV to call the Republican
conference and I quote a continued
failure theater end quote so I
understand that we're trying to throw
red meat to an extremist base but we're
wasting the Public's time and we know
that the Senate will laugh off all of
these charges and let's remember the
bigger
picture some of my friends on the other
side of the aisle don't want to really
govern they're not serious about
solutions that could actually become law
and they're obstructing 14 billion do in
emergency supplemental funding they
voted against hiring hundreds of
additional border patrol agents and of
report ports of entry and have opposed
the Incredible S resources that we've
try been trying to send around
technology supporting organizations on
the ground support for border patrol
agents and many other types of funding
and I also want to remind the committee
and the public that President Biden on
his first day in office sent a
comprehensive immigration plan to
Congress which Republicans have refused
to act on I also want to note that
secretary mayorcas has continued to try
to negotiate a bipartisan sensible and
Humane a Humane approach to actually
fixing our immigration system and trying
to actually address the issues that
remain along the border because
Democrats agree there are issues and
challenges along the border and we want
to see those fixed now as an immigrant
myself I also I've always believed this
is a nation of immigrants we should
never forget that this country was based
on so much hard work and labor of
immigrants that now live all across this
country and our immigration system won't
be fixed by this impeachment process and
it certainly won't be fixed by their
proposal which is hr2 and let's set the
record straight about hr2 the bill would
end Health and Human Services funding
for legal representation of
unaccompanied children in immigration
ation proceedings it it would
essentially send children to detention
camps and the bill subjects all
unaccompanied children to an accelerated
removal
process as we know in horrible
conditions at these facilities that we
have seen over the last few years and
quite frankly we know this is not just
solu not a solution but it's inhumane
and cruel to demonize some of the most
vulnerable people that are coming to our
country we want to address the root
causes of migration we want to ensure
that legal pathways are followed we want
to make sure that that folks receive the
support they need back in their home
countries and we certainly want don't
want to defund organizations like
Catholic Charities that would rip away
Aid to communities and to migrants
across across our country and along our
border the idea that our border problems
which have needed a bipartisan solution
for decades would be solved by hr2 is
just not true it's an anti-immigrant
policy and we should reject it thank you
and I yield back the gentleman yields I
now recognize Mr Latrell for the
gentleman from Texas for his five
minutes question thank you Mr
chairman thank you all for coming here
today Mr Bowman I I appreciate and
respect your opening statements where
it's probably the most educated I've
been on where it comes to constit
constitutional law and the process that
we're in right now so thank you for for
that education U qu I have my first
question for you sir is can you give me
the definition of a high crime and MISD
meor I think no single definition is
satisfactory in every case but I think
Charles Black's is a pretty good general
statement that is to say eye crimes and
misdemeanor should be ex extremely
serious offenses in the way that serious
crimes like treason and bribery are
extremely serious second from that let
me go off for that one sir that's a
great point is the selling of fentel
inside the United States causing
hundreds of thousands of deaths over the
past years considered a high crime in
your
opinion I'm unaware that the secretary
has sold any fentel no no no no I'm not
directing that to the secretary I'm
asking you is the selling of fentel
inside the United States killing
hundreds of thousands of Americans over
the years considered would be that be
considered a high
crime if you could establish Bo that's a
yes answer all day long you don't say
yes that's bad did that possibly all
right so let me ask you have no evidence
that that ever happened there's there's
no there's no evidence that hundreds of
thousands of people over the past few
years have died from Fel over I'm
unaware of any evidence that secretary
Marcus has ever sold I'm not talking
about secretary Marcus I'm talking about
F that's what we're here to talk about
are we not Congress secretary if you'll
allow me to finish if you'll answer my
question I'm getting my point it's your
time so you can with you know all right
so let me ask you this since we're we're
unhinged on the fentel desk do you
consider slavery a high crime
is there any evidence that secretary
mayorcas has enslaved anyone this is
getting a little bit more complicated
than I thought it was going to
be I want to know if I'm supposed to go
back to the folks in my district and
tell them that the individual
responsible for securing the American
borders is falling short because the
United States is one of the top
countries on the planet for sex slaves
we lose a 100,000 people
a year to fentel overdoses and the
individual responsible for protecting us
is Mr mayorcas that's where I'm going
with that the fact that you didn't jump
on top of and say that those things were
absolutely involuntarily the worst
things ever is graphically disturbing to
me I pitched that one up as a softball
buddy and you failed
miserably I'm from Texas I feel this
every
day and my colleagues and I we have our
disagreements and I went down to the
border with my with the other
Republicans I didn't have a polo on I
didn't get behind the podium I talk to
everybody down there that works down
there I talk to the ranchers the
citizens and they tell me every single
day that we are
overwhelmed and Miss Titus brought up an
amazing Point yes if we move remove Mr
mayorcas Mr Biden will put another
Democratic member in that spot we know
that I'm here for this reason I'm
sending a message that my people can no
longer take
it we are dying by the droves every year
I have to look at the mother I look the
mothers and fathers that lost their kids
for I got look at them every single day
when I'm out in the
district and it's all coming across our
Southern border through the ports of
Entry yes I got it but if you're
responsible for securing our our borders
then you better act like it and this
individual is not and that is the
problem sir
period in a
discussion these atrocities that we are
seeing you can't explain 40 million
people are enslaved on the planet 40
million and America is leading up top
with that problem and you ask where they
come from they come across our Southern
border and our northern border and that
sir is the responsibility of the
secretary and since he has failed to
conduct his job for the past few
years we need somebody else now I'm not
I'm Mr may orcus I I've chatted him up
he is a family man he's a good man and
I'm G to be crucified going back home
and saying that I've toen SP face to
face and I he he I I bet he adamantly
disagree would disagree on the fact
slavery is horrible the fentel discs are
horrible but there was a mother sitting
in front of this commit
months ago last year and sat there and
looked at every single one of us she
lost her mother and her daughter to a
Coy running through the town killed them
both she had to she had to stand there
in the emergency room while her daughter
died she looked us all in the face as
you guys are absolutely doing nothing
you're doing nothing so when we go to Mr
May orus is say hey we need to act on
this and nothing's happening sir that is
an absolute problem I yield
back J Ys I now recogniz Miss Clark from
New York the gentle lady from New York
for her five minutes of testimony thank
you Mr chairman and good afternoon uh
let me first start by thanking our
Witnesses for joining us this this
afternoon uh today uh you know it's
clear that Maga Republican attempts to
impeach secretary Marcus have nothing to
do with his performance and everything
to do with the Loyalty oath most of my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle have sworn to Donald Trump after
the house twice impeached Donald Trump
once for attempting to bribe an ally to
investigate his political opponent and
interfere in US elections and again for
inciting an Insurrection against the
capital to steal an election some of my
Republican colleagues want to settle the
score by impeaching someone anyone in
the Biden Administration secretary
mayorcas was sworn in on February 2nd of
2022 less than six weeks later Senator
Lindsey Graham floated the secretary
should resign during an appearance on
Fox News in May of 2021 Congressman bigs
appeared on the 1 and said that
secretary morakis has got to go and
introduced articles of impeachment the
secret of the secretary in August of
that year the secretary had not yet
served six
months other Republicans piled on that
call in the months that followed in
April chairman green fundraised off his
planned impeachment efforts telling his
donors to quote get out the
popcorn unquote but secretary Marcus is
hardly the only member of the Biden
Administration Republicans have
disagreed with and then tried to impeach
Congressman Perry filed articles of
impeachment against attorney general
Garland in October of 2021 congresswoman
Taylor green filed articles of to
impeach the Attorney General in August
of 2022 FBI director Christopher Ray in
May of 20122 and filed multiple articles
of impeachment against President Biden
sometimes more than one time in the same
day Congressman Norman filed articles of
impeachment against secretary blinkin in
August of 2021 and Congressman Mills
filed articles of impeachment against
secretary Austin in August of 20 23
meanwhile Republicans have filed
multiple resolutions to expunge the
impeachments of Donald Trump I'm
concerned that my Republican colleagues
failed to understand the gravity of
impeachment so uh Professor
Bowman the founders engaged in robust
debate when defining the criteria for
impeachment in your view did the
founders intend for impeachment to be a
frequently used process to coerce the
executive branch into policy decisions
or a rarely used tool reserved for
Extraordinary behavior that meets the
definition of high crimes and
misdemeanors certainly the second
congresswoman I mean the key Point here
is not only that impeaching secretary
morcus will will affect absolutely no
change in Border policy border
legislation but even if impeaching uh a
cabet secretary could really accomplish
something consequential it would be
terrible for the country because it
would overthrow the basic principle of
separation of powers in which uh on
which the Constitution and our system of
government are actually based Congress
and the executive are supposed to work
together to solve the country's problems
they're often going to disagree about
how to do that but in our system the
solution is the hard work of
legislation of negotiation of compromise
of Coalition building
uh impeachment is not and never has been
the answer and it is quite clear that
the framers intended it not for that
purpose whatsoever they intended it for
the most extraordinary circumstances and
simply to resolve you know a a a a
partisan political debate or to change
policy is not
it thank you um for your response and Mr
chairman I yield back General lady Yi I
now recognize Mr strong and uh for
the committee room Mr strong will be the
last and then we'll go vote and come
back at 2:15 so Mr strong you're
recognized thank you Mr chairman
attorney general canuteson um I was glad
to see you mention in your testimony
that Secretary of my orcus has regularly
hidden behind the concept of prosecut
prosecutorial
discretion I like how you said that
because that right there is one of the
big issues today specifically we have
talked about secretary pures abuse of
prosecutorial uh discretion in the uh
enforcement and removal of illegal
aliens to the United States I want to
highlight again secretary Marcus's 2021
memo in which he stated the fact that an
individual is a removable alien
therefore should not alone be the basis
of an enforcement action against them he
went on uh to list factors that ice
agents should weigh when deciding
whether to pursue enforcement and
removal or not
uh attorney general canuteson as a
former prosecutor yourself does it make
uh make any sense to give Credence to
mitigating factors when considering
whether to prosecute someone that has
already been proven to have broken the
law when they crossed our border
illegally Congressman certainly not
especially when there's specific
directive in federal law that requires
that person be detained and be
prosecuted U the the idea that
individual prosecutorial discretion
suddenly means you have the right to
blanket on mass pardon people or or or
parole them into the the the heartland
of the country that simply does not
exist in statute I I I agree with the
concept generally of prosecutorial
discretion on a caseby casee basis and
indeed that's what the federal law
allows but that's not what's being done
here it's being just implemented on a
mass scale while wide open on mass and
that is simply not justified anywhere in
federal code thank you I must say I was
disappointed to see that the factors in
favor of uh removal didn't include this
uh uh significant financial and human
cost to American citizens our hospitals
are inundated with illegals schools are
overrun with non English speaking
setting other students back and now New
York has sent teachers and American
students home uh and turning public
schools into bunker houses for illegal
aliens this is totally unacceptable uh
attorney uh General Bailey and Canon you
both specifically mentioned in your
testimony that you uh do not view the
crisis at the southern border uh as a
resource issue in other words you both
agree that additional funding wouldn't
solve uh what is happening at the border
can you each explain to the committee uh
why this is the case certainly that's
what our lawsuit about his refusal to
build the border wall is all about he is
flaunting the commands of this body he
is nullifying your constitutional
authority over the power of the purse
and when that Authority is no longer
effective impeachment is the last option
I would point out that what we have here
is not a policy disagreement willful
violation to carry out a an explicit
directive of this body and an abdication
of His official
duties
Mr chairman Congressman I I would add
that you know that resources are being
moved down there regularly I I mentioned
I'm a northern border state we have
nearly 600 miles of border with Canada
in my state there's a large Customs and
Border control border control contingent
in Montana most of those individuals
have told me they've been they've been
cycled down to the southern border the
problem is not the number of Agents down
there the problem is they are being
instructed by secretary mayorcas to
stand down and to not not follow federal
law that's the issue here thank you on
September the 6 2023 the DHS office of
Inspector General released its report
titled DHS does not have assurance that
all migrants can be located once uh
released into the United States that
title alone should concern every single
person in America this investigation
reviewed nearly one million migrant
records and found that addresses for
more than 1
177,000 Mig migrants were either missing
invalid for delivery or not legitimate
residential locations that uh that's
nearly
20% uh if you if you look at this and
that right there is totally unacceptable
we talk about leadership by the
Secretary of Homeland Security well you
think about this the first thing that I
saw at the southern border on one of my
many visits is I noticed
2,288 border wall panels in storage I
came back to DC and found out that those
2,288 uh panels being stored in three
different states costing the American
taxpayer more than $300 million This Is
How They solve or try to work to solve
the problem at the southern border this
is totally unacceptable and this is uh
another reason that we're here Mr Bowman
you're a constitutional law expert
should president Trump have been
impeached for a Russian hoax where the
steel dosier was created and paid for by
the Clinton
campaign what do you think about that
should that should that have happened
what were you teaching in your classroom
go go ahead and answer the question and
then we'll uh that'll the gentl Mr
chairman I'll uh I'll yield to you I
know he doesn't want to answer that
question no you do you not want the
gentlem okay all right the the gentleman
y we will recess now until 2:15 we have
two votes I need to chat real quick with
the witnesses just to make sure that you
guys can stay we're in recess
I guess snap
short thank
you
for
oh thank you
sorry
for
e
so
person
yeah
for
spe
e
tell
for
dress
yes
sir
your
yes
okay
give
my
ex
sir yes sir thank you of
course
than
for
e
come
I now recognize uh the gentleman from
Oklahoma Mr biken for his five minutes
question uh thank you very much Mr
chairman thanks to the witnesses uh for
being here especially we got somebody
that traveled all the way from Oklahoma
to be here um I just want to reiterate
after the break uh just for the American
people to know you know it's important
that we follow the rule of law uh I I I
love you know commonly said now to be
the rule of law team um it requires
discipline it requires focus it requires
that you know we don't turn ourselves
into a Banana Republic Article 2 Section
4 says the president vice president and
all civil officers of the United States
shall be removed from office on
impeachment for conviction of treason
bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors the Constitution absolutely
uh gives authority to impeach and remove
the president vice president and all
civil officers for treason bribery High
crimes and misdemeanors this to tool was
inherited from English practice in which
Parliament impeached and convicted
ministers in favor and favorites of the
crown in a in a struggle to reign in
abuse of power that's the historical
precedent on this and let me back that
up okay so it's been talked about this
morning uh Federalist 65 has some
admonitions has some warnings and it
says the subjects within the context of
impeachment in federal 65 written by
Alexander Hamilton it says the subjects
of its Juris talking about impeachment
are those offenses in which proceed from
the misconduct of public men or in other
words from the abuse or violation of
some public trust it goes on to say that
the model from which the instrument of
impeachment the idea of this institution
has been borrowed pointed out the course
to be the convention in Great Britain it
is the province of the House of Commons
to prefer the impeachment and the House
of Lords to decide upon it to part just
like we've employed in our constitution
several of the state constitutions have
follow followed this example as well as
the latter as the former seem to have
regarded the practice of impeachment as
the Bridal in the hands of the
legislated body upon the executive
Servants of government you know why I
love that I grew up in the performance
horse industry and uh I learned three
stage stops from a father who trained
cutting horses professionally you sit
down they feel the pressure of that then
you say whoo and then they a well-
trained well disciplined animal learns
that when they feel the the three-stage
stop coming they're going to park it
without having to lift the 4 ounces of
the rains the
bridal the problem is we've got men and
and women who serve in positions of
authority and they the definition
according to aqaa of a ranian horse I
love this is is willfully guided
willfully controlled the problem is when
you have men and women in influence who
aren't willfully guided and willfully
controlled by the Constitution the
Constitution and and as stated by
Alexander Hamilton the job of the of the
legislative body is to grab the reins
and say whoo and we have an out of um
out of of place out of their flood plane
Bureau bureaucracy within Homeland
Security that is doing what they want to
not following the rule of law so with
that said the question is before us are
there instances of fact where mayorcas
has flippantly disregarded the laws
enacted by Congress Point One Parole
section 212 d5a of the immigration
nationality act says parole shall only
be granted on a case-by Case basis only
for Urgent humanitary reasons or
significant public benefit my orcus has
not done that he's created broad parle
programs for 30,000 aliens per month
Cuba um Haiti Nicaragua and in Venezuela
without evidence of humanitarian reasons
or without significant public benefit
point two resources in fy2020 Congress
explicitly appropriated funds for
constructions of barrier systems our AG
is has talked about from Missouri the
part of your lawsuit was over this
barrier systems along the Southwest
border my workers refuse to comply with
congress's appropriation refuse to build
barrier systems as as Congress said as a
will of the people the power of the
purse point three detention section 235
B1 of immigration nationality act
outlines the procedures by which aliens
attempting to enter the United States
without a Visa or proper immigration
papers are to be detained and removed my
orcus has not done this his agency has
released several million illegal aliens
who should have been detained and
deported question Mr Bowman you've been
invited by the Democrats to to provide
your uh you advice as a professor um and
you said that the impeachment of my
orcus needs to be based on not policy
differences but it has to be quote has
to be subversion of the Constitution
another quote from you for
illegal illegal ends or serious offenses
is that correct yes or no that you said
those
statements has to be subversion of the
Constitution for your legal ends or
serious offenses yes or no I'm sorry
could you repeat that you're speaking
rather youve said it it's on record I
need to kind of watch my time and move
on through this to my to the call to the
attorney general's in the room room is
not administering the laws of the land a
serious offense ille for illegal ends
does it rise to the level of high crimes
and misdemeanors please each of you
please answer that question absolutely
Congressman it does rise unequivocally
yes we got three attorney generals who
say that the violation of these laws is
a violation of the enforcement of the
law and is grounds of high crimes and
misdemeanors which the Constitution
clearly lays out is high crimes and
misdemeanors is a is a reason for
impeachment what we tolerate we Empower
Congress has to do its job and send a
strong signal if you don't follow the
law you're going to be out thank
you gentleman Yi I now recognize the
gentleman from Arizona Mr Crane for five
minutes thank you Mr
chairman thank you guys for showing up
you guys aren't exactly attorney
generals of Southern Southern border
states are
you but even you guys are feeling the
effects of what's coming across that
southern border is that true absolutely
yes yes gentlemen how long roughly did
it take you to become Attorney General
go ahead Mr nudson well roughly how long
I mean campaign for the better better
part of a year no entire career just
like 20 years 15 years how long did uh
roughly 15 years what about you Mr
Drummond 40 Mr Bailey been practicing
law for 10 years yeah so you guys just
didn't wake up one day and say I want to
be attorney general and snap that
happened right I noticed that some of my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle have been trying to diminish um
you know your your qualifications what's
the primary responsibility of the
federal government Mr
nudson primary responsibility of the
federal government is to carry out and
execute the laws of the Congress yeah is
it to protect uh our unalienable
god-given rights as well absolutely what
about does our government have a
responsibility to protect its citizens
Mr Bailey yes are any of you guys
familiar with article 4 section 4 of our
constitution often called The Invasion
Clause anybody yes I'm going to read it
real quick the United States shall
guarantee to every state in the Union a
republican form of government and shall
protect each of them against Invasion
now there's arguments right now about
whether or not this is an invasion but
it's tough to argue when you have the
equivalent of a combat division size of
illegals coming across our Southern
border for those of you that don't know
that's 10,000 individuals every single
day in Invasion and we've talked about
what comes with those individuals from
crime you know the economic burdens on
on our citizens
the PE the the families being destroyed
at fentol you guys are all familiar with
that you guys see them every single day
in your own States is that correct yes
thank you are you guys aware of the job
title of Alejandra mayorcas Mr
nson a specific job title Secretary of
the Department of Homeland Security
Homeland SEC Secretary of Homeland
Security now I'm no I'm I'm no
constitutional scholar Mr Drummond but
just from that job title alone would you
assess that maybe his job might be to
secure and protect the Homeland he has
the duty to control and guard our home
Mr Bailey is uh secretary my orcus doing
that he is has abdicated His official
legal responsibilities and his moral and
ethical responsibilities to this nation
Mr nudson is he doing that absolutely is
not he is derc in many of those duties
one of one of my colleagues on the one
of my colleagues talked about the
difference between individuals Crossing
on the terror watch list between the
Biden Administration Secretary of my
orcus and the former Administration
those numbers were a start contrast
under the last Administration 14
individuals on the terror watch list
came through were encountered at that
southern border under this
Administration and we still have several
months to go in this new year already
300 individuals on the terror watch list
are you gentlemen aware of how many
individuals it took to pull off
911 not 300 yep it's about 19 does it
concern you guys as folks that are
concerned with the security of citizens
in your state that something like that
might happen in the United States of
America or your
state absolutely yes yes I want to you
guys talked about it all day long and I
find it interesting that my colleagues
on the other side of the aisle kept
saying that we're grandstanding here or
we're just campaigning you know or these
are political differences but you guys
all three of you and we went over how
long it took you to get in your position
you guys are like the highest long
enforcement uh officials in your state
you guys all went over not just the
policy differences but the different
laws that this secretary is in violation
of Mr nutkin can you go over some of
those really quick I absolutely can I
think the secretary is clearly in
violation of um USC 8 section 12
1225 uh he's he's clearly violated
section 1182 by granting Mass parole
uh immigration and natural ation act
makes very clear that that is not to be
granted on a mass basis that's to be
granted on a caseby casee individual
basis yep thank you sir Mr Jack Miss
Jackson and Mr Bowman both said that
betrayal of a nation is one of the
criteria necessary for impeachment if
allowing the equivalent of an army
division of illegals coming across the
southern border on a daily basis causing
the deaths of hundreds of thousands due
to fentol every
single about 100,000 every year enabling
the sex trade in this country along with
the importation of thousands of MS-13
gang members causing the Encounters of
individuals on the terror watch list to
go from 14 under the last Administration
to 300 on this this Administration lying
to Congress about having operational
control costing the American taxpayers
hundreds of billions of dollars for
housing and care for these illegals and
more than 24,000 people from the
Republic of China coming across our
Southern Border in this last year alone
if those aren't betrayal to a nation I
don't know what is thank you gentlemen
for your time Mr chairman I yield back
the gentleman yields uh I now recognize
the ranking member for 5 minutes or for
his closing arguments thank you very
much and let me thank our Witnesses for
for being here today uh this hearing has
confirmed what we already know uh uh
over four hours ago this so-called
impeachment is nothing more than a
thinly veiled political stunt my
Republican colleagues have failed to
make a case for impeachment failed to
understand the Constitution and fail to
do anything to address challenges at the
border this hearing has been more
Republican rehash attempting to impeach
the secretary over policy differences
instead of working with Democrats on
immigration and Border policy reform
demonstrates that Republicans are not
only interested in using border security
as a political talking point
this impeachment scheme is simply more
distraction from a do nothing Republican
Congress they talk about hr2 a
disastrous bill they wrote In Secret
without any opportunity for Democratic
input knowing very well that it was Dead
on Arrival in the Senate the so-called
investigation that chairman green has
launched has been conducted with a
predetermined outcome from the start and
now our Republican colleagues are trying
to pretend that this effort isn't
political Mr chairman the American
people will see through such an
incredibly obvious sham no matter how
many times my Republican colleagues
twist the facts to suit their narrative
there is absolutely no evidence that
secretary mayorcas has committed an
impeachable offense no amount of yelling
finger pointing F righteousness
indignation can change that fact and we
heard
today from Professor Bowman the
consensus from constitutional Scholars
is clear Republicans have not made a
case for
impeachment even Republicans favorite
constitutional scholar Jonathan Turley
has come out against this impeachment
not just because it is baseless but
because it is
what a dangerous precedent it would set
as Professor turle explained impeaching
secretary meus quote is a slippery slope
that we would be wise to avoid indeed it
is precisely the Temptation the framers
thought that they had avoided by
rejecting standards for Mal
Administration it's no accident that
Democrats invited a legal scholar to the
this hearing while Republicans invited
three partisan politicians the
Republican Witnesses have no expertise
in impeachment one of the witnesses is
facing 41 ethics charges another witness
state supreme court unanimously found he
failed to perform the plain unequivocal
and ministerial duties of approving
information for ballot initiative
but again no expertise on impeachment
all we learn today from the majority
Witnesses is that some Republican
politicians don't like a democratic
cabinet secretary Republicans are
pretending to provide accountability
just like they pretended to legislate
these past months in his opening the
chairman said there was no reasonable
alternative to pursuing
impeachment let me suggest suggest some
Alternatives Republicans could have
supported funding increases for border
security operations instead of voting
against them Republicans could provide
additional resources requested by
CBP they could engage with
Administration on
immigration they have not Republicans
have failed to act at every turn instead
of working with Democrats they've wasted
a year chasing a Basel
impeachment to satisfy their most
extreme right-wing members but as what
we've heard today impeachment was never
intended to be used that way the
Constitution's framers expressly did not
include
mismanagement misgovernment or
maladministration as a basis for
impeaching a cabinet
secretary my Republican colleagues May
disagree with this Administration A's
border policy and that's their right but
to use impeachment to sell such
differences is
unconstitutional Mr chairman I
understand the last year has been a
tough one for republicans and that your
party would like to deflect attention
elsewhere this is very kind of thing
that the framers work to avoid when
establishing grounds for
impeachment three years
ago Mr chairman you wrote Unity can be
only achieved by focusing on where we
find Common Ground instead of drawing
new battle lines and that every one of
us has a role in Bridging the Divide
when chairman green is ready to listen
to his own words I want to be clear
Democrats will be here waiting to work
on responsible and effective policies to
strengthen our border security use using
the levels of power that the
constitutionally constitution actually
gives Congress but until then we'll
continue calling this sham impeachment
for what it is a political stunt with
that Mr chairman I yield back gentleman
Yi I before I start my uh closing
statement I just want to make an
observation it's it's very interesting
that we point out that Mr uh uh Bishop
can't talk Pol political stuff about
running for election but all the
testimony from the have been about
politics about running for office and
about so it just find it fascinating but
anyway um I recognize myself for my
closing statement today we've heard
powerful testimonies from the Attorneys
General of three states who are dealing
with the consequences of secretary
marcus' border crisis I want to thank
you all for being here and for your
testimony and of course I'll thank Mr
Bowman for being here as well as our
witness has made it abundantly clear
every state is now a border state and
why are we here we're here because
secretary meorc is's policy policies
were exploited by the drug
cartels and have done incredible damage
to the United States those
policies were in violation of the laws
passed by this Congress the Congress
said the Ina detain parols an exception
based on Extreme circumstances not 85%
as the secretary says is now just being
released into the country willly neilly
it's violation of Law and interestingly
enough so he's disregarded the
Congress he's also disregarded the
Judiciary Branch four court rulings said
cease and desist because you're breaking
the
law I'm sorry I took the oath at age 17
to defend the Constitution against all
enemies foreign and
domestic the oath wasn't to the American
people it wasn't to defend the land mass
or the flag it was to defend the
Constitution this secretary took the
same oath to defend the Constitution
well I'm sorry but I think the
Constitution of the United States says
we write the laws and not him get to
pick and choose whatever the heck he
wants to when he is the executive branch
gets to ex execute the laws he is to
execute the laws as
written that is the Constitution he took
an oath
to four court orders cease and desist
because you're breaking the law and he
disregards the Judiciary branch and
continues his poliy in fact he doubles
down creating more policies that do even
more Catch and
Release which is why I think it's
intentional he's abusing his position to
force his woke immigration policies on
the United States of America despite the
fact that Congress is supposed to fix
those immigration
laws on top of
that back on script now on top of that
secretary Marcus knows full well the
consequences of these policies but
instead he's rever reversing course he's
doubling down it's worse he's been to
the Border he's seen the numbers he's
seen the fenel seizures he's met with
The Grieving families he knows about the
cartels he knows about the human
trafficking and the child exploitation
yet he doesn't change a
thing in fact as I said he admitted to
the border of Patrol the other day and
closed
meeting 85% are being
released despite the intentionality
behind this open border secretary meus
is attempting to skirt the consequences
of act his actions he has continuously
tried to deflect blaming climate change
Wars in Latin America non-existent DHE
DHS budget cuts there have been no
budget
cuts and what is the cost of secretary
mayorcas this border crisis fenal poison
is killing thousands of young people
every year we learned from attorney
general Bailey that a total of 43
Missouri children died from
unintentional unintentional accidental
they didn't have a
choice we had a testimony over here if
Americans would just stop using drugs
those little babies didn't have a choice
that baby on a vbo in Florida certainly
didn't have a
choice she wasn't able to just say no my
heart breaks for this baby and her
parents because of this border crisis
thousands of mothers won't get to see
their kids graduate thousands of fathers
won't be able to walk their daughters
down the aisle at those weddings as a
parent myself that breaks my heart
that's the human cost and apparently I
need to explain to my
colleagues while it is accurate that
most of the fenel is seized at the CBP
uh you know intercepted at the official
points of Entry this is because those
facilities are equipped for that purpose
yet we ALS also know that drugs are
coming across between ports of Entry it
simply isn't being caught this is
because border patrol agents are tied up
processing people at the Crossing sites
and it's not like we can put the entire
border as an x-ray machine or a CT
scanner and while my Democrat colleagues
may not believe me I hope that they will
believe those on the front lines border
patrol agents have told us that drugs
coming between the ports of Entry is a
key driver of the rising fental crisis
why else says fentel gone on the street
from 98 bucks a hit to 25 bucks a
hit after this uh secretary came into
office it's because of the simple supply
and demand of coming across the southern
border we've also heard that Federal
officials from federal officials that
they all they they believe they only
apprehend roughly 5 to 10% of the fal
coming
in that that's from the border they're
only catching 5 to 10%
what really matters here isn't how much
fentel is caught but how much fenel is
flooding the neighborhoods we got three
guys here from three states just
discredited by the ranking member but
they're here to testify what's happening
in their states and you know what some
of us heard
you some of us heard you people are
dying because of
this because of secretary markus's
border crisis cities and states
Nationwide struggle to pay First
Responders while healthc care and
education systems falter in fact medical
care for undocumented aliens will cost
$7 billion this year we also heard from
attorney general Drummond about the
organized criminal operations and that
some illegal aliens run once they arrive
he shared that in Oklahoma alone the ag
office prosecuted 50 complex
multi-jurisdictional criminal cases most
of them involving Mexican and Chinese
drug cartels coming across the southern
border make no mistake these human
trafficking and drug trafficking rings
are sophisticated and they've taken a
foothold in the United States because of
our open
border finally we can't negate the
credible threat this open border poses
to our national security with emboldened
Islamic terrorist groups and an
increasingly aggressive communist
Chinese party we have to wonder how many
Bad actors are in that 1.8 million known
Goda ways and how many are in the
unknown Goda
ways well we won't know until something
tragic happens
when we embarked on this investigation
almost a year ago we knew there would be
roadblocks and it would be a formidable
challenge no matter how hard this
process gets Homeland Republicans will
not back down the American people
deserve answers accountability and
ultimately an end to the Border crisis
look if you have a secretary a cabinet
secretary who breaks the laws or refuses
to obey the laws of Congress refuses to
adhere to the
rulings of a Judiciary the cease and
toist orders from a judge I mean that's
lawlessness on his own
part if it were me a republican I'd
expect to be impeached you can't have
cabinet secretaries that just decide to
do whatever the heck they want to
do the committee on homeland security
has made every effort to ensure that
this investigation was thorough we do
not take this lightly the homeland
security committee spent a almost a year
countless hours we held 10 hearings we
heard from two dozen Witnesses released
five reports totaling 300 Pages we
conducted numerous transcribed
interviews border Chiefs multiple visits
to the border to see for
ourselves I don't hold any personal
animosity toward secretary
morcus but I sure as hell don't want to
see him continue as Secretary of
Homeland Security not after the pain and
turmoil and Cha chaos his policies have
inflicted on the American
people and when Congressional oversight
demonstrates beyond a shadow of a doubt
that executive branches are neglecting
their Duty overstepping their Authority
ignoring laws passed by Congress it is
our duty to act to defend this
institution to defend the
Constitution also just to be clear this
is the responsibility of Congress the
Supreme Court made it clear and United
States versus Texas according to the
court and I quote even though the
federal courts lack article 3
jurisdiction over the suit other forums
remain open for examining the executive
Branch's arrest policies for example
Congress poses an array of tools to
analyze and influence these policies
those are political checks for a
political process end
quote so no so not only do these
proceedings have the support of the
house the Supreme Court has pointed to
impeachment as a source of relief for
States suffering a border
crisis put together orchestrated by a
secretary who is violating the laws
passed by Congress and disregarding the
Court's orders now before I end I'd like
to address a few things that other
things my Democrat colleagues have said
let me start with saying I'm very
disappointed in the ranking member for
misquoting me he claimed that I wrote
that I will not support another dime to
DHS this is inaccurate what I wrote I
will not support another dime to DHS
until the policies of hr2 are signed
into law and enforced by the
administration and we're talking about
the supplemental so we're not talking
about the budget which has already gone
through and pass the house we're talking
about additional dollars in a
supplemental to suggest that I would
defund the Department of Homeland
Security is disingenuous at
best I can tell you there been a lot of
Democrats who' said defund ice and
defund the
police I never said defund Homeland
Security
and I'd also like to address the claim
that secretary Mar Arcus isn't at fault
here that he isn't to blame for the
economic crisis in Latin America I agree
but poverty in Latin America is nothing
too new and actually poverty rates in
Latin America have stayed flat from last
Administration to this
one further I'd like to reiterate
the Democrats sent these articles to
impeachment to our committee in
November they sent it to this
committee the homeland security
committee has the authority of the house
to conduct these impeachment proceedings
and that's exactly what we're going to
do Democrats can bring up a New York
Times popcorn story all they want to
they keep talking about Maga Republicans
and former president Trump this and that
but it's clear these are deflections
because they have no answers for the
piss poor performance of secretary
mayorcas and his
policies and let me just point out my
Democrat colleagues are quick to talk
about kids in cages under Trump but did
a single one of them Mission the 85,000
missing uacs under President Biden of
course not the hypocrisy in this room is
palpable and of course our guide should
always be the intent of the framers of
our constitution the founding fathers
regarding how Constitution was intended
to be understood but too often in
political debates people can fall into
inconsistency for possibly partisan
reasons I get that for example Professor
Bowman wrote a book on impeachment in
2019 called high crimes and misdemeanors
a history of impeachment for the age of
trump in it he States the power of the
house to impeach cabinet secretary
secretaries quote remains important as a
signal of legislative displeasure with
administrator personnel and policy end
quote yet today he's testified on
multiple occasions that policy alone
isn't enough for an
impeachment that's what Professor Bowman
wrote When Donald Trump was president
but now in his written testimony at page
three he writes that impeachment and I
quote should not be attempted based on
simple policy disagreements between
Congress and the executive branch end
quote I guess that was then and this is
now but let me be clear no one is
supporting impeachment of secretary
mayorcas over policy differences the
impeachable offenses relate to
violations of the law insisting on
enforcing the laws written by Congress
is not a policy difference it is a
fundamental requirement of the
Constitution lastly I got to tell you I
was
appalled from someone on the left who
said suggested this has all been a waste
of time we're here today because it is
our duty to provide oversight and hold
the executive branch accountable and yes
this includes the option to impeach we
cannot allow a cabinet secretary to to
violate to violate the laws disregard
the Constitutional structure lie to
Congress under oath all a massive harm
to the Americans and do nothing about it
and if a republican were head of DHS and
committing these same acts I can assure
you we wouldn't tolerate it from them
either it is the Homeland Securities
committee's responsibility to provide
oversight of DHS this is what we were
elected to do this is what we were
appointed to this committee for now this
might not be how you want to spend your
time but it certainly is how we must be
spending our time and I ask the members
here today in fighting to stop the
needless death of children def fental
poisoning a waste of time is it a waste
of time to try to protect those kids
trying to stop criminal cartels from
wreaking havoc on the country a waste of
time it's not and the insinuation is
appalling what has been a waste of time
the amount of taxpayer what has been a
waste the amount of taxpayer dollars
this border crisis has cost the amount
of people who have died as a result of
fentel flowing across our Southern
border the amount of migrants who lost
their lives making the dangerous Journey
the amount of money state and local
governments have had to spend cleaning
up secretary meus is
mess this is where the real waste has
been not these official
proceedings as we continue these
proceedings in the coming days it's
important that the American people
remember the facts that this body once
again Embraces our constitutional
responsibilities when I took that oath
as a young boy on the plane at West
Point it meant something to me then when
I took it when the people of Tennessee
sent me up here it meant just as much if
not more we
will support the basic basic tenants of
that document and that is Congress
writes the laws the president executes
those laws the Judiciary interprets
those laws and they have a
responsibility to do their Duty and we
do also without objection that that ends
my closing statement and without
objection the committee stands
adjourn
that